e
good morning everyone oh that's loud
move that back a little seeing it is uh
after 900 a.m. I want to welcome you all
to the environment and agricultural
committee had a pretty busy day today on
the schedule hearing uh bills relating
to Solid Waste and Recycling policy
we're going to start our day by doing a
pledge of allegiance and I'm going to
call on representative Murray to lead us
please please
stand flag of the United States of
America to the rep stands one nation
under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
all
well thank you um we're excited to get
back to doing hearings and we've got
little bit of a thin committee today for
various reasons we have some other
members that have other commitments and
in uh scheduled vacations and things of
the such but we'll make do with what we
have here couple things I want to go
over before we go into the first hearing
uh the blue sheet and pink cards are
over on the table for those of you who
are new to the process I I know last
year we didn't do any of that since we
did uh a lot of online testimony but if
you're uh in support or want to sign in
with a position of the bill not just
support you can sign on the blue sheet
if you want to speak you need to make
sure you get a pink card up to us here
so that we can get you on the list and
know who uh to call on for
Testimony we will not be executing any
bills today just taking testimony on the
bills that we
have the other thing I want to go over
which is new to us is the uh microphones
in the video this is now being live
streamed this is the first time that
that's happened and so for the committee
members uh you have microphones on the
desk in front of you I would ask that
when you're done speaking you turn your
mic off I've been told that if more than
three of us have a mic on it will kind
of block out everybody and you won't be
able to hear plus it will cut down on
the background noise that is going out
to the members in the audience and the
members that are joining us uh online
through YouTube and viewing us so if we
can all try and remember to do that
would be helpful
the last announcement I have is we're
going to be taking a hard stop at 12
o'clock for a lunch break I built I know
I've got a lot of bills scheduled and
I've hopefully built time enough in for
all the testimony but if we uh need to
recess you know the next bill if we get
close to that time then we'll we'll do
that and and uh you know just put it on
hold and finish the one that we're on
but I do want to be fair to the
committee and give them a a good chance
to have a solid hour for a lunch break
so we'll be doing a hard stop at new and
resuming at
1 okay uh our first uh bill that we're
going to bring up is House Bill
1111 and I will open the hearing on that
and I will call
on uh representative partial to in
introduce the
bill please remember to turn your mic on
there thank
you
for the members at home I did forget to
announce this is uh House Bill 1111 is
establishing a commission to study
extended producer responsibility go
ahead BR
par
excuse me representative do you have
your mic on thought there you go oh I'm
sorry I'm so
sorry backwards at the start of my work
life in the 70s I drove a semi and
hauled local produce and wine to
marketing hubs it was a well-known joke
on the CB radio about some truckers and
firms that engaged in the practice of
midnight dumping which was the
intentional spreading of toxins and
hazardous waste by leaving a nozzle
partway open as a truck traversed the
interstates I'm happy to say this
practice met its rightful lend with
legislation that required proper
labeling and tracking of hazardous
materials this rightfully put the Cradle
to grave liability for disposal and Wass
back onto the
producers now I know this committee will
be spending this day reviewing numerous
bills on expansion of New Hampshire
landfills and I wonder how many of these
landfills could be rendered unnecessary
with wiser stewardship of our local
resources House Bill 1111 is a modest
step in that direction as it would use a
financial incentive to encourage
producers to consider the entire life
cycle of their product and packaging
this would include the cost of disposal
and landfilling currently being absorbed
by our municipalities and rate
payers and this is key hb1 1111 is the
first step in internalizing the cost of
disposal to product design well-drafted
EPA legislation will place the burden of
disposal squarely upon the creators of
the product and establish a clear line
of responsibility that would relieve
local government from the currently
hidden cost of
disposal consumers have little control
over
packaging even my favorite sale
addressing with 100% of profits going to
charity has recently switched to
single-use
plastic on average for every 100 bottles
that are produced 24 are in current use
nine will be incinerated seven recycled
and 60 end up clogging our
landfills the full cost of product
packaging does not show up at the time
of purchase rather it appears on my
Municipal tax bill the cost of
disposable shift entirely from the
producer to the consumer and has real
cost in terms of both economics and the
environment
two other states have already enacted
extended producer responsibility
legislation as has a major portion of
Europe and Canada I cannot predict what
will be the best fit for our New
Hampshire way experiences taught me the
best Solutions come for mostly have
direct experience with the problem
Gathering the various stakeholders with
a study commission should result in a
workable Grassroots
solution a common model that is used
elsewhere would have the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
contract with an established pack
material stewardship
organization the stewardship program
will collect certain waist streams costs
from participating municipalities
connection with packaging
products with some exceptions producers
of packaging material will be liable to
pay into a fund based on the amount by
weight of packaging materials associated
with the product they seller distribute
in New
Hampshire producer payments received by
the stewardship organization will be
used to reimburse participating
municipalities for certain Recycling and
waste management
costs in addition of the payments of
Municipal reimbursements a stewardship
organization could use a reasonable
portion of producer payments to cover
operational expenses and provide for
education and infastructure aimed at
reducing packaging
waste producers May offset some portion
of this
payment obligation by implementing
programs to recycle or or reducing the
amount of Packaging associated with the
products they sell or distribute in the
state or meeting other program in
centers in
summary the problem of choking our
transfer stations with unnecessary
packaging would rightfully be shifted
back to the producers of such waste this
would result in lowering the cost to our
municipalities and their tax Bas while
this is environmental legislation it's
every somewhere related to the cost
taxpayers incur in support of their
Municipal TA or stations wish to thank
the committee and I will do my best to
answer any questions you may
have thank you representative parall
anybody have any questions
for representative piig yes um so uh I
have thank you for taking my question
and uh one thing one question that comes
up frequently when we are faced with uh
a bill requesting a commission is
whether a committee would be an
appropriate uh shift where because uh in
order to um make it a little bit more um
limber let's
say I can understand that I know we are
swapped with committees at times it
feels like however in a situation like
this I feel there's uh a complicated
issue that would could be made simpler
by gathering the uh the
um Gathering the concerned people who
are concerned with this and already
working with this problem together and
coming
with with a workable solution that
everybody could live with rather than
dictating from
above thank
you representative hola hi thank you for
taking my question you had referenced to
other states that have uh enacted this
as well and do you do you know those and
what how long their programs have been
available I know that this past thank
you for the question um I know this past
fall
um Maine had legislation signed into
place and the timetable for actually
moving that program forward I could not
I could find out perhaps but I could not
give you that's okay I just wondered if
there was some longevity and the other
state is uh Oregon and that also was
very recent I will admit there's not
longivity to this at least not in the
United States however as I said earlier
and you may hear from other testimony
there are places around the globe that
been doing this for a very long time
successfully thank
you
representative Bixby thank you for
taking my question actually this is not
my question but uh representative um uh
kaplan's question which he's not going
to be here till noon so obviously he's
not going to make this hearing uh but he
was wondering how does the proposed
committee interact with or or would
would it interact with the solid waste
study
commission um how would a oh how would a
committee act yeah so so how would how
would the proposed uh the the commission
proposed under hb11 1111 interact with
the existing Solid Waste study
commission I would hope that uh there
would be some I really can't say I mean
I I I'll be very to be very Frank it'd
be speculative of me to say that
okay um fair enough thank you I I should
add I would hope that there'd be quite a
bit of crossover and concerns be heard
in both directions I think that would be
the obvious thing to expect to occur but
thank
you are there any other questions from
the
committee thank you representative
parshall and we appreciate you
introducing the Bill thank you so
much next I'd like to call
Representative
oxenham good
morning
thank you to the chair thank you for
members uh for being here can you hear
me or do I need
thanks extended producer responsibility
moves the cost of managing postuse
products partially or fully from local
governments and rate payers to the
producing that should be taxpayers
excuse me I'm permissed te used to
talking about rate payers taxpayers to
the producing
industry it is based on the polluter
pays principle making waste producers
responsible for the Recycling and
Disposal of their waste or to pay the
costs thereof asking the industry to
take back products at the end of a
product's life encourages the industry
at the outset to design the products in
ways that enhance their reusability and
their sustainability
it
incentivizes new thinking about how to
create the products that we all use
every
day it minimizes the impact of waste
Downstream which impacts our waterways
our air our water our Scenic resources
on which New Hampshire tourism
depends epr is increasingly recognized
worldwide as an efficient waste
management policy it improves Recycling
and most importantly reduces the amount
of land filling of products and
materials epr programs have been used in
Canada and the European Union for at
least a
decade it ensures that producers
manufacturers brand owners and first
importers of products and packaging are
given the legal
responsibility for collection res
cycling and endof life management or
else pay the cost
thereof 25 out of the 28 member states
of the EU have epr schemes in place and
annually they save in excess of 79
million tons of
materials Japan and South Korea have
programs for a wide range of projects
products excuse
me these these programs can be done
across the board or they can be done for
Selective waist streams they could be
done just for Batteries just for
electronics just for paper products uh
there are many many options out there
which is a very strong reason to have a
commission look into this and make a
determination of possibly where we would
start and where we would like to end up
with an epr program here in New
Hampshire
um I if if I may take one more moment to
to tell a a brief story to bring this
into Focus 30 years ago when I was a
Sierra Club member living in Maryland I
saw an independent documentary which
I've not been able to resurface but it
was called the next Industrial
Revolution and it focused on a Swiss rug
making company and the company was
suddenly hit with a charge for disposing
of its toxic material Cals which were
the dyed remnants of carpets and so the
carpet manufacturer said I'm not paying
that money that's crazy and so he
redesigned his processes used vegetable
dyes not only cut any kind of waste
stream coming out but created an income
stream because he could then sell the
remnants of the carpets as fertilizer so
that's the kind of rethinking that epr
can create and I'll take
questions representative Bixby thank you
for taking my question so um the prime
sponsor s seemed to suggest that this
was aimed mostly at uh epr for packaging
and I'm wondering if if the study if the
study should be aimed much more broadly
than that to include all possible
Avenues towards epr and if there's a a
direct um uh or or if there if it's sort
of aimed at one uh category or another
thank you for the question it's an
excellent suggestion and would certainly
be a welcome Amendment uh from my end
and I'm I believe that with
representative parshall and
representative Suzanne Smith as well
again we didn't want to take up you know
too too large a bite but sometimes you
you you know you unders shoot and
looking at the full uh gamut would would
certainly pay off for for the taxpayers
of the state
follow up yes so I I don't actually see
in the bill where it says specifically
that it would would be in fact
specifically packaging so I'm not sure
that it actually requires an
amendment
or um I I have the bill with me but I
don't have it in front of me and I I'll
take your word for
it perhaps I misunderstood your question
I understood you to say that you thought
it was limited and you wanted it to be
expanded well I guess the the question
was that the the the prime sponsors
testimony suggested it was limited but
in fact I don't see in the bill that
there is a limitation I think that was
just an
example that was just an example he
wasn't saying that it was limited okay
sorry certainly could could the prime
sponsor answer the question uh um Madam
chair Madam chair
Judy oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry is it possible for the
prime sponsor to answer a question that
I'm not able to answer
sure thank you again for the question
was my hope and ambition that a study
commission would have
broad authority to
investigate any possible legislation uh
along lines of extended producer um
responsibility so while it's not
specifically addressing situations like
electronic disposal or car
disposal typically those kind of uh
issues are addressed in the same
packaging in other places and I expect
they would be here as well so I hope
that answers your question hope that the
bill is Broad enough to inou that I I
think it
is thank
you
representative
that's I just had a com it says here the
commission shall submit a report honor
before September 1st
2022 is that's incorrect yes it it
certainly is um and we would expect to
have that changed if if it can't be
changed here we can change it on the
Senate side but thank you for ke9
pointing that
out and I'd also like to note that I
have uh circulated the national caucus
of environmental legislators fact sheet
on epr for packaging which may also be
the reason that you thought that the
bill was limited to packaging
um that the bill is
not but it does speak to the general
issue as on the back
sheet any other questions uh represent
just uh there in terms of exist um epr
uh programs that actually exist in the
states um I I I know that the ones for
packaging are fairly new but uh are
there not some programs for electronics
in other states and for maybe car tires
and that sort of thing I thank you for
the question I believe that those may be
more locally um produced programs rather
than being um in State Statute I but I
know that there are the two State
programs in Main and Oregon and I don't
know of other
Statewide programs here in the United
States although as I said in the EU 25
out of 28 member states have epr
programs thank you thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative Murray just if
I may have your testimony for the record
if you have that please or you can email
it to the committee I'll I'll send it to
you by email thank you thank you thank
you very much for the opport opportunity
to speak to you today all right thank
you very
much next up is uh representative
Suzanne
Smith yes
sure
okay all
right anyone else would like to speak on
this
bill um sorry I don't know your
name
oh all right sorry I didn't see we don't
have a card a pink card for you we do oh
down at the end I'm
sorry all right then uh Bonnie
Christie good morning and welcome to
environment and agriculture good
morning um
good morning chairperson Vice chair all
members of the committee I did email in
my whole statement last night so you
would have email copies of it so I'm
just going to try to skip through and
summarize um I'm from hopkington
and I'm going to speak about our local
situation not about the national and all
the details of epr um but I'll talk
about our numbers thank you
yeah I do support this bill and I speak
as an individual citizen today but I am
also a member of the Hopkinson Webster
um refu disposal committee that operates
our transfer station and I'm the
chairperson of the Hopkinson waste
reduction committee so I think that the
trends that we're seeing in hopkington
are probably representative of of many
if not most New Hampshire towns and that
is that our waste load is going way up
and even with aggressive recycling we're
not keeping up with
that our committee the waste reduction
committee was previously named the
recycling committee but when recycling
rate wasn't keeping up with the mssw the
municipal Solid Waste load we renamed
our committee the hopkington waste
reduction committee so here's a few
numbers to illustrate what I'm talking
about between 2019 and 202 21 our MSW
waste Lo went up by 260 tons that brings
us to a total of
3,228 tons a year to dispose of in a
landfill or
incinerator just for reference this is
equivalent to 14 elephants a week going
into our Hopper or 35 of my vehicles I
drive a Honda CRV so I calculated the
weight and the equivalent so that's sort
of like what what we're
doing our tipping fee jumped this year
from $72 a ton to $82 a ton and it's
going to go up $5 a ton until 2025 so
we'll be paying close to $100 a ton to
dispose of our
waste the total expense to our taxpayers
right now was just about
$265,000 to get rid of our
mssw and the expense to operate our
trans for station is
$566,000
747 tons of metal construction debris
electronics and so forth that was
another $20,000 cost so this describes
what we're dealing with at our transfer
station and I'm I'm sure that it's
similar to what other towns are
experiencing so why is this happening
we're we're all wondering why is this
happening what can we do we divert as
much waste as possible to recycling we
kept 50% of our construction and demo
debris out of the
landfill um are we do aggressive
recycling with the source separating
method rather than single stream
recycling for all the other goods and
that always brings the highest revenue
that you can get from
recycling but even with all this the
percentage of our total mssw that was
recycled in
2021 dipped to its lowest rate ever
14% we are not encouraged by that number
so we feel like something has to
change um my feeling is HB 1111 would be
a first step in that direction it would
start a conversation about Source
reduction you don't produce the waste on
the front end you don't have to dispose
of it and pay for it on the other end
this was at source reduction was at the
top of the legislator's hierarchy for
preferred strategies for Waste
Management which was put into place in
1990 we have never done it at the very
bottom was incineration and then last
landfills and those are the two things
that we've done all these years we've
done no Source reduction we need to flip
the pyramid and start focusing on
that so epr I don't know all the details
of I think this is a study commission to
figure out what it would look like the
Maine epr law and the Oregon epr law are
very different so we'd have to do what
works for New
Hampshire but as the the bill sponsor
said the producers of the products and
the pack packaging would share the
responsibility with us as consumers and
with municipalities for disposing and
paying for the the products at the end
of life so this incentive would create
more recyclable goods there would be
recycled more and it would limit limit
packaging to only what's necessary to
protect a product or make it safe for
the
consumer as I think Lee oxenham
mentioned epr Is Not A New Concept it's
done for pharmaceuticals mattr
paint
batteries um it's in summary it's time
for Source reduction it's at the top of
our hierarchy it's been there for 32
years the legislature was the one that
said it and it's time to implement it so
I hope that the committee will establish
a committee on epr and provide M
municipalities with some tax relief for
their Solid Waste
Management my only concern which I think
was just addressed is that it does seem
that that dat that's in the bill is
unrealistic for reporting out um so I
hope that changes and I'm also following
the solid waste working group that
representative eel is chairing and my
thought is that a study Commission on
epr could do a deep dive because epr is
just one of the things that that larger
group will be looking at over a year or
two so that's what I would see as a
role thank you very much appreciate it
any questions from the committee
representative pix just a a quick
question about your your uh construction
debris sorting is that something that
you do sort of inhouse with uh your
staff at the at the transfer station or
is that uh done by a another business
yeah no we have a separate pile for CN
construction and demo and the staff
keeps an eye on that to make sure all
the uh recyclable or can be sent for
alternative energy use is sent out and
that comes to about 50% in our town
thank you thank you representative
Dy question what is the population of
hopon and can I verify did you say 26
million tons of
MSW is that no 200 our we produce well
our population I'm going to say around
um and our our total waste in tonnage
that we produced in 2021 was
3,228 tons that was 260 more tons than
what we were producing in
2019 and I would be happy to share with
you a graph of our Trend in solid waste
our our Solid Waste has gone up between
2016 and 2021
almost
20% in our tonnage our population
according to our best numbers has only
grown
5.4% so the waste is going way up out
oftion to the number of people and we
don't really understand that but we
really are anxious to do something about
it than thank you um representative
Kennedy
thank you
for thank you for taking my question you
also include the town of Webster as your
yes we share with
Webster it's
joint I actually have a question um do
you know what percentage of your town
budget goes towards Waste
Management I don't have the percentage
but our operating budget uh last year
was
9,783 23 66,800
46 and then there was also
42,000 for solid waste and I'm not sure
what that means but that's what is in
our town report from last year thank you
yeah any other questions from from the
committee
representative um muray no that's okay
thank you for taking my question um so I
just wanted to go back and clarify did
you say initially though that there was
a
$265,000 cost
forn yeah that's what it cost that's in
our our total tipping fee for the
3,228 tons that we generate and send out
to the landfill thank you it used to go
to incinerator now it goes to TurnKey in
Rochester okay thank
you all right any uh further questions
yes representative M I just have one
last question just to to bounce off of
Representative Kennedy's question if you
share your landfill with Webster is that
correct do you know the the population
of
Webster I don't it's much smaller than
Hopkinson and I know our population grew
5.4% and I think theirs grew like like
1.4% in that time period so uh it's
definitely you know we we pay proportion
we have pay
pay more proportionally than we do so
anyway yes thank you you're
welcome any further
questions all right seeing none thank
you thank you very
much okay anybody else that would like
to speak on this buiness bill before I
close out yes
sir uh good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you very much
I'll be very brief I did submit written
testimony actually on six bills last
night which you should all have via
email uh John Tut Hill from aworth New
Hampshire Sullivan County uh and all I'm
going to say on HB 11111 is I strongly
support the bill uh one of six bills I'm
supporting today um and I will just urge
you to consider this carefully it's long
overdue it's time for us to begin uh a
new I think sort of a new regime with
solid waste in the state of New
Hampshire and that I will let you get on
to your next Bill thank you thank you
sir any
questions all right seeing none thank
you anyone else before I close out
11-11 all right seeing none uh we're
going to close the hearing on House Bill
1111 is re mamila here
yes we didn't have a pink card from you
so I wasn't sure if you were
here all right we're going to call on uh
open up the hearing on house Bill 11:21
and call on rep M Miller to introduce
the bill and when you get a chance could
you please fill out a pink card and send
it up to us thank
you
when you're ready go ahead got to put my
glasses
on I'll say it again good morning
chairman Perl and good morning esteemed
colleagues I am representative Linda
Milla and I represent rafton
one thank you for giving me this
opportunity to present the case for
House Bill
1121 I hope to Show members of this
committee and all of my house colleagues
that house bill 1121 is a bill that is
needed now appropriately protects our
residents and businesses and imposes no
additional cost to the state this bill
is needed now largely because the solid
waste disposal Market doesn't respect
State
boundaries the market is regional in
nature and is dominated by private
for-profit firms meaning that these
firms can and do move large quantities
of solid waste across St
lines if we are not diligent New
Hampshire is on a Glide path to becoming
the snc for much of New England's trash
I say this because other states New
England states like Maine and Vermont
have updated and strengthened the
regulatory requirements for new landfill
construction making it harder to build
new landfills in those
States New Hampshire has not kept pace
with this and the other changes in the
market so this makes New Hampshire an
easy target for firms looking to import
trash from other states the scenario
that I worry about is that corporations
with no particular ties to New Hampshire
and with huge profit potential will'll
be importing large amounts of outof
State trash because we haven't provided
good incentives to protect the residents
and the businesses in New Hampshire from
damages caused by their
landfills and when those landfills those
damages rather do become evident those
firms don't have good incentives to make
restitution for the damages that they
occasion this is a regulatory Gap that
needs to be
filled there is evidence that the solid
waste industry vastly
underestimates the possibility of
contamination of land air and water
water from their
landfills for example a top engineer for
the second largest Solid Waste FM in New
Hampshire recently told Dees that with
technology his firm employs
contamination of our Water Resources
including wetlands and lakes and
rivers quote can't happen
unquote well I'm here to tell you that
yes it can happen and it already is
happening in our state with in the last
year we've seen a huge leee discharge
which undoubtedly contained pasas and we
don't know the extent of the resulting
contamination in addition we've just
seen a settlement of a federal court
case involving pasas discharged into a
major New Hampshire River the bottom
line is for those two examples only that
we don't know whether there has been
damages suffered by residents and
businesses
now I want to turn briefly to how HB
1121 will work it's relatively simple
Bill designed to help ensure that New
Hampshire residents and businesses will
be made whole in the event they they
incur Dam aduc from landfill
operations it's important to point out
that shity bonds are common vehicles to
ensure that industrial firms take
financial responsibility for the safe
closing of their assets and also that
firms required to obtain shity bonds
have a number of options in other words
there's no one siiz fits all
problem an additional way shity bonds
can be used to is to ensure that a
landfill owner operator can and does
meet its financial responsibility to pay
restitution to individuals and
businesses that are harmed by a landfill
not just at the closing of the
facility but during the life of the
landfill this is the Central purpose of
h121 I think the case for
h121 can best be made with a simple
example what happens to New Hampshire
residents and businesses that suffer
damages from an existing landfill
without assurity
bond and what happen happens with a
requirement for assurity bond well
consider landfill accident such as Lee
leage that contains pias which
contaminate nearby water supply Wells
the affected residents and businesses
May suo the landfill owner or operator
for damages and win restitution in
court without assurity bond requirement
there is no assurance that the landfill
owner operator will make such
restitution for example it may declare
bankruptcy or it may prolong litigation
without purpose other than in an attempt
to avoid payment of
restitution with assurity bond
requirement those individuals and
businesses damaged by the landfill
operation are significantly more likely
to be paid
restitution landfills are a risky
business business and the citizens and
the businesses of our state deserve the
added protection to be held harmless in
the event of a landfill accident this
seems like the least that we can and
should
do moreover aurity B re Bond requirement
for for new landfills allocates the risk
of landfill accidents to where it should
be on landfill owners operators not on
our citizens and not on our
businesses thank you for
listening thank you representative uh
will you take any questions sir there
any questions representative vixy yes
thank you for taking my question so just
to be
clear uh you there was an original
version of the bill and you circulated a
uh an amendment and the original version
talked about insurance and was a little
bit less clear about how
the uh the the bond would work and does
the amendment clarify that uh I believe
so you all have a copy
correct yeah I know I was trying to read
it quickly while you were talking and
pay attention I sort of agree it seems
to kind of uh just tighten up the
language a little bit for the most part
maybe a little more clear thank you any
other questions for representative
call so um sort of an as I'm wondering
if this would be an example of where sh
Bond would have been useful uh one of
the issues that we've had in the last
few years is the K landfill in uh
Portsmouth and
Greenland and the uh it's been very
difficult for residents around that
landfill to get proper um help with
their drinking water and and make sure
that's paid for by the owner of the
landfill would the if there had been a
shity bond in place would that have
helped I believe so I'm not an insurance
expert luckily for all of you but uh I
believe that would apply thank
you uh representative Aaron thank you
for taking my question and good morning
good morning good morning so um I'm
interested to know why you are limiting
this bill to private owned Solid Waste
uh landfills and not including
municipally owned ones well midle
municipally owned landfills are exempt
because they created by the consent of
residents and under jurisdictional rules
that determines at least in part if and
how residents are compensated for
damages caused by the municipality while
privately owned landfills are made
subject to HB 1211 because under New
Hampshire law and rues
permits for construction of new
landfills are issued by the state and
the municipality has limited opportunity
to oversee the approval and operation of
the land gotcha thank you very
much any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much next we'll
uh call up uh director whim app from New
Hampshire
Dees
good morning director go when you're
ready good
morning for the record uh my name is
Mike whim sad I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services want to thank you for the
opportunity to comment on House Bill
1121 uh first I want make it clear the
agency is not taking a position on this
bill um we do uh have a few concerns
that we just wanted to articulate and
they're outlined in the letter that's
being circulated right
now um I guess really we can divide are
concerns mostly into two two groups
first the bill requires and again I I
have not seen the uh proposed amendment
that was just discussed so I I my letter
of testimony addresses the bill as
introduced and my remarks today are are
as
introduced um so the bill as it was
introduced requires applicants to submit
evidence of compliance with insurance
insurity bond requirements of the state
and federal government and um this is a
point of confusion for Dees because as
the agency that regulates and permits
Solid Waste facilities we are not aware
of any specific insurance or shity Bond
requirements um so as a result we don't
enforce any so if there are such
requirements that wouldn't exist in the
future then obviously that would be
integrated into our program but for now
um that language in the first section of
the bill is is is confusing to us and um
we're not sure what effect that
provision would actually have or how we
would implement or enforce it the second
uh issue is the bill requires an
applicant to post assurity bond um or
the operator of a landfill to post
assurity bond to protect against any and
all damages I think is the terminology
that's used that individuals and
businesses May incur as a result of
operation of the
landfill and as the bill is written it's
unclear to us what damages means it's a
very broad term and and we're not sure
who would um what would constitute a
damage who would be the Arbiter or the
who would determine what a damage was to
an individual or a business and as such
um we're not sure how we would enforce
um such a provision um also because it's
so broadly written it really amounts to
some uncertainty of the scope of the
provision so we're not sure if you know
ostensibly such a bond if if one were to
be posted would need to be in place for
decades throughout the operating life of
the landfill and and during the post
closure period of the landfill um and
given the uncertainty of scope and the
length that it would have to be en forc
we're not really sure if such a bond
would be obtainable in the market um
we're not experts on bonding so that's
not us uh weighing in it just it it
causes us to ask ourselves that question
and uh I think I'll leave it at that
and' be happy to uh answer any questions
the committee may have thank you
director um actually I have one
myself so if aurity bond is put in place
you may not know the answer this does
that survive a
bankruptcy yeah that's beyond uh my uh
that's beond my area of expertise okay
thank you so any other questions for the
director seeing none I guess we want to
let you off easy today thank you for
your
testimony all right next up we'll have
uh Tom Tower from the North Country
Alliance for balance change Tom is
needing four minutes to speak thank
you
good morning Mr chairman uh to the
members of the House environment and
agriculture committee thank you for the
uh opportunity to uh to testify today
for the record my name is is Tom Tower
I'm a resident of Whitefield and
speaking here today on behalf of North
Country Alliance for balanced change uh
to speak in support of House Bill
1121 before I begin I'd like to thank uh
representative Massa Miller and all of
the other Bill sponsors for their
tireless tireless and and hard work
House Bill 1121 is a very important
piece of leg legislation because it will
help Pro protect the residents and
businesses of New Hampshire from bearing
the entire cost of personal and business
damages that may be caused by newly
constructed
landfills without this bill the
likelihood of restitution for those that
incur actual damages from the operation
of a new landfill is in question
this is not fair it is not consistent
with free market economics and it is not
uh good for our
state It is Well recognized even by
individual firms in the solid waste
industry that landfills are a messy
business dreams of evidence exists that
in businesses
including to their health their safety
their economic excuse me security and
their to their quality of life Federal
and State Environmental Regulators have
significant responsibilities to look
after the natural
environment uh and as an example to
ensure in advance that a landfill does
not cause untour damage to the
environment in general but the
responsibilities of environmental
Regulators to protect individuals and
businesses from damages is extremely
Limited in the case of New Hampshire by
default damages incurred by individuals
and businesses must be addressed through
legal action the value of this bill is
that it codifies the landfill permit
holder must bear the entirety of the
cost associated with landfill operations
including the potential cost associated
with damages to nearby individuals and
businesses the mechanism used in this
bill is to require prior issuance of
permits the permit holder to show
evidence to Dees that it has a shity
bond to back stop any restitution that
may be required by courts to hold
harmless those damage by landfill
operations in the absence of such shity
bonding permit holder may have the
incentive to walk away from its
financial responsibilities if there are
large claims of Damages there are many
examples of industrial firms walking
away from their assets for such reason
as an example by declaring bankruptcy
although some May consider this unlikely
the consequences would be great as it
would leave an alert those damaged by
the operation of the landfill this bill
therefore provides added assurance that
nearby residents and businesses that
incur damages will in fact be
compensated for those damages there are
other reasons to support this bill it is
entirely consistent with and codifies
the basic principle that polluters
should pay damages that they cause it is
also entirely consistent consistent with
the basic principle that industrial
firms must internalize all of their
costs that their uh activities occasion
and in this case including the costs
associated with harm to nearby residents
and businesses House Bill 1121 is a good
bill with bipartisan support that relies
on Market forces rather than
administrative determinations to protect
New Hampshire's residents and businesses
it closes a regulatory Gap that exists
with respect to holding landfill permit
holders accountable and it helps protect
residents and businesses that may be
harmed by the operations of new
landfills best of all it will cost the
state nothing to
administer thank you and I'm happy to uh
answer any questions thank you for your
testimony any questions from Mr
Tower seeing none thank you we
appreciate you coming in thank you
everyone is there anyone else that would
like to testify on House Bill
1121 do you have a copy of your
testimony then as well thank
you seeing none I will close the hearing
on 1121 and representative Davis could
you run over and grab the blue sheet for
me on
uh House Bill 1121 before we close it
actually we should read the results of
that I forgot two on house bille 11-11
maybe you could grab both of
them we're all a little rusty from not
having done this a couple of
years
I have not seen so the question was do
we have access to the online tallies
because I know there are folks that sign
in online I do not have that currently
but I will certainly make sure we can
try and get that make it part of the
record so on House Bill 1121 we have
three people signing in uh Fred Anderson
is in favor Rick Banger is against and
John Tut Hill is in favor with that we
will uh close house Bill 11:21 and we'll
take up House Bill 1134 in about 3
minutes is rep buo here for introducing
34 is representative Smith here this is
an
Smith
no
for
e
okay uh it's uh 10:01 we're going to get
started with
uh the bill uh HB
1134 and I'm looking for representative
Buco who is the Prime sponsor of this
bill to open it
up so let me open
this hearing for this bill uh it is
House Bill 1134 establishing a
commission to study proper labeling and
disposal of disposable wipes
good morning representative Buco good to
see you the uh microphone is to your
left just so you know uh the committee
did receive via email your testimony
I have I have it okay everybody have it
okay we're all
set thank you madam chairman for the
record my name is Tom buo and I
represent uh Carol County District
number two which includes the towns of
chadam Conway Eaton and haes location I
appear before you today to introduce
House Bill
1134 and to request that the environment
and agriculture committee recommend
House Bill 1134 ought to pass the intent
of house bill Bill 1134 is to establish
a commission to study the proper
labeling and disposal of disposable
wastes disposable wastes include
premoistened non-woven sheets including
baby wipes disinfecting wipes and all
purpose cleaning
wipes uh West Wastewater operators are
finding huge clumps of these wipes and
Wastewater collection uh Wastewater
collection and treatment systems these
wipes are being flushed down toilets but
they are not not biod biodegradable they
are plugging up Wastewater systems and
must be manually
removed it is the intent of 1134 host
Bill 1134 to establish a commission to
study the proper labeling of packaging
and the proper disposal of Wipes we
recommend a commission of professionals
experienced in the field to study this
issue report its findings and to make
any recommendations for proposed
legislation in the final report
uh thank you madam chair sorry that I
read this but I I sent it I sent it in
when I wasn't sure I was going to make
it today no
worries any questions from the
committee representative dsy uh yes I
believe one of our questions was why a
commission again and not a committee
because this seems to be a fairly narrow
Focus well we thought we we thought we
needed to have professionals that work
in the field and have experience with
this issue as opposed to just um having
a commission of a a committee of
legislators go right
ahead but correct me if I'm wrong if if
it is a committee you are free to call
in all of the experts to give you
testimony is that correct yeah and and
the reason I say this is I believe it's
EAS get a easier and faster to get a
committee together than it would be to
get a commission together so I just
wanted to kind of emphasize
that I well you're correct that that a
committee could call in anybody they
they needed but um we thought with this
issue that there's so many this is
happening all over the state and all
over the country probably because these
things are just getting flushed and um
in fact
I talked to our superintendent yesterday
and he said that even uh these things
these masks are getting flushed now and
they're causing a lot of problems
because they have the straps that catch
the rest of the stuff they have the
metal
bands
but it's the wipes that are that are
clumping up and and actually causing
damage and and they're costing money
because it has to be you know we have to
put Personnel on that to clean it out so
I the the the the the intent of of a
commission of professionals was just to
have people that work in the field and
are familiar with the
issue okay thank you any other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you and I would
like to then follow uh up with
representative Suzanne
Smith
good morning and welcome to environment
and
agriculture it's good to be back it's
been many years since I served on this
committee but it's one of my favorites
and um I am for the record I'm Suzanne
Smith I live in Hein and I represent the
towns of pouth Hein and holderness uh
grafting County District 8 and I am here
as a co-sponsor of this
bill in preparation I kind of walked
down the shell of the aisle where the uh
supposed flushes are in my local
supermarket some of them have a little
tiny thing on them that set has a
picture of a toilet with a slash through
it most of them did not and some say
write on them
flushable and it's really challenging
for the people who who haul sepc who
clean septic systems and who operate
wastewater treatment plants because
these things do not biodegrade they
wreak havoc with with uh homeowners
septic systems in rural areas like mine
and they wreak havoc with wastewater
treatment plants which ends up costing
municipalities and even the state a lot
of money when the wastewater treatment
plants are not operating up to
speed the one of the problems with
Banning flushes or saying you have to
label them is the Commerce Clause
because most of these companies are not
in New Hampshire they are National and
we have to deal
with we can only uh regulate what is in
our state as far as uh you know
mandating that they be labeled properly
I know Dees is trying to do a good job
they've got a s they've got little
stickers you can put in public restrooms
that say you know no no flush Ables kind
of stuff but you know it's just an
ongoing problem and and the reason for
the commission is to as representative
Buco said to get everybody to the table
to really work on this and try to come
to some kind of New Hampshire solution
which will help us with the situation um
as far as committee versus commission as
representative Duty uh spoke
of it's
challenging either way but a commission
where everyone you know when you have a
committee you you can call individuals
in but when you have a commission
they're an active part of the committee
the commission and always at all of the
meetings and there can be dialogue
amongst the different groups rather than
one week we have uh Bia come in the next
week we have the septage haulers come in
so I think that's one big reason for the
commission and also there isn't as much
of a disconnect when we have an election
in November of this year you know if
it's a committee the whole committee can
change whereas a commission you only
have a couple of legislators changing
but the rest of the people are still
active members so I can take any
questions but um I can take any
questions representative Bixby yes thank
you for taking my question so is there
any sort of industry or a legal standard
of what counts as flushable and what
doesn't count as flushable well you know
I look I have no idea I mean I looked at
baby wipes um online and in the
supermarket some say Do not flush and
some give no indication but the do not
flush thing as I said is this little
tiny Circle it's like the little
recycling logo you know and then some of
them say in big letters flushable so
it's it's challenging okay but you're
not aware of any sort of Standards no I
I am not aware some other people who are
going to to testify probably are aware
of that thank you thank you
representative
Duty uh yes uh I had a friend um who uh
used flushable wipes and $500 later uh
found out that they were not flushable
yeah um when her toilet got clogged up
on a Sunday so even if there is labeled
how would we hold companies responsible
for or maybe mislabeling their products
that's the reason for the commission
thank you for your question
though we don't have the answers right
now
representative thank you for taking my
question and thank you madam chair uh
are there any numbers I can imagine on
the costs of this for municipal waste uh
entities but do we have any numbers as
far as like what this costs every year
for water districts to to handle this
problem I do not have that information
but I know there are people behind me um
I believe they're signed up to speak I
hope they are okay thank you very much
thank you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much oh I'm sorry representative Paris
thank you um thank you for letting me
take uh thank you for taking my question
this is not a question but I just want
to say I really appreciate that you
introducing and you co-sponsor this bill
because it is critical I
always concerned about the way uh the
wipes and and some of them like um
another state representative said it
before um they say uh disposible and um
in in a lot of times that um it's been
issues with uh toilets and um other um
especially uh when you you have a sect
assistant so I really appreciate um do
you introduce him this de thank you
thank
you okay appreciate it thank you I'd
like to call next um Ray Gordon new
representing New Hampshire
Dees got some hand outs
sure
yeah thank
youate
it
yes we just pass him
around
yours okay why don't you why don't you
go
ahead thank you my name is Ray Gordon I
work for the New Hampshire Department
environmental services for over 25 years
for the majority of that time I've
worked for the Wastewater engineering
Bureau at Dees as well as I'm now
stationed at the Franklin Wastewater
facility running the winaki River Basin
program which is a state-run wastewater
treatment facility so both in my present
job and my former job I've been dealing
with wipes since
2013 and all of these products that are
flushed down the drain whether they
should be or not and and one of the
biggest problems is is we're not quite
sure what should be flushed down the
drain and what shouldn't be and I know I
learned a lot myself when I was
researching uh these
topics and you'll see going around just
some of the impacts that happen to the
Wastewater plants because of that
confusion that residents like yourself
have when you using one of these
products and you'll see three photos one
of them is from the city of Kean one of
them that's this one
here and it was in the newspaper and
you'll find hundreds and thousands of
these photos from wastewater treatment
facilities across the state and across
the country even our own state run
Wastewater facility the winaki River
Basin program we have another photo that
appeared in Dees Publications showing
the impact of all of these wipes when
they congeal and clog the sewer line and
need to be removed by staff and another
situation this is a pump that cost us
$115,000 to repair because it was
damaged when they were trying to remove
the clog from the pump so it's just
three isolated examples that I could
show in my very short time up here to
show you the impacts of the
problem and just a real quick summary of
what's happening the Wastewater systems
were designed for toilet paper and your
waste to go down the drain they were
built for those
materials and now we have all kinds of
new products this one's actually a
mitten that you wear on your hand to
wipe your butt
and if you try to rip it you try to tear
it nothing is going to happen to it it
is like almost
indestructible and you would think you
know you might not see them out there
cuz they're quite expensive that's $20
on Amazon for this package but they're
finding them in the sewers of nashaa
that's the only place so far that I've
heard that they have found these
particular wipes but they're combined
with all kinds of other thing Lysol
wipes Preparation H Summer's Eve
traditional baby wipes and if you look
at the packaging of all of these it's
crazy you you can't tell which one
should be flushed not flushed even some
of
them say they should be flushed but this
particular product I learned at a
training session the weekend that it was
introduced clogged all the pump stations
in the town uh where it was first
introduced
so what we've done as an industry in
Wastewater A lot of the facilities have
installed Grinders over the year at a
cost anywhere from maybe five to $15,000
per
grinder and the level of wipes and other
products just keeps increasing now we're
all looking at adding screens to our
wastewater treatment system so that out
in the collection system these screens
can pick up pull the materials out and
actually remove it before it gets to the
wastewater treatment facility right now
our winaki River Basin program
wastewater treatment plant has a screen
at the treatment plant and it removes
most of the material but we're in
process of anywhere for well for around
$180,000 for just the equipment alone
trying to work it into our budget
that our staff could then install those
screens out in the 60 miles of
collection system so that they don't
cause problem in the sewer
lines so that's just a
quick overview of the topic and that's
why Dees really supports a commission um
to answer your question about the
standards there are some
voluntary
standards that have been adopted by the
wipes
manufacturers to show whether things are
flushable or not but nothing is
enforceable and those standards have
labels here that you could see that show
do not flush and then they have a symbol
that should be used on everything that
truly is flushable and passes those
standards and um I think there's
actually two sets of standards and I
think if we do have a commission we
should study which standards maybe are
better to implement learn more about
these products and what we could do to
hopefully make them
enforceable um but Dees strongly
supports the standards to at least start
to engage those topics and with that I
could answer any other questions you
might have thank you representative
Murray I did have one question you had
stated that um I think you had mentioned
$180,000 is that per screen or is that
just for the purchase of the screen and
the labor yeah so what these are it's
$180,000 for a large bar screen it's a
mechanical thing that rotates and moves
goes down into the Wastewater pulls the
wipes back up and puts it in a trash can
and then the trash can be hauled off for
as solid waste because all of these
products should be that are not truly
flushable should be disposed of as solid
waste so for our size system it's
$180,000 you get a bigger pipe it could
cost more you get a smaller pipe it
could cost less but that's the quote I
have inh house for a piece of
equipment thank you any other questions
from the committee represent
froma hi there thank you um do you know
of any other states that
have have some examples to show if
they've taken the lead on this yeah and
in fact this materials here are removed
from uh a display I have from the state
of Maine they were the leaders in the
region and we learned a lot from them
and because of that we developed the New
Hampshire what's flushable uh campaign
and basically our message has been do
not flush anything but human waste in
toilet paper uh because of the confusion
it'd be nice if we you know could help
people know what is truly flushable and
not other states that are leaders
California
Washington uh Indiana uh there's a few
others too um but there there's a
handful you can count them on two hands
that are working on these issues at the
moment
and at least one maybe two states have
actually passed labeling legislation
already as well and follow on pleas sure
go ahead do you know what states may
have passed labeling legislation the
reason I'm asking is because I'm I'm
just curious of how that works when you
have a product that is obviously shipped
all over to every state yeah how you are
labeling that for your state yep so
Washington state was the first one to
implement it and the association of
nonwoven manufacturers who developed the
flushability
standards uh were a key in helping in
supporting the legislation and we've
actually been having conversations
recently with the industry because what
it is it's their standards that the
states are enforcing so because they
want a Level Playing Field for their um
you know their members as far as when
they sell products because they know
they're getting a bad wrap you know you
have a good product you know like this
one here that is probably the most
flushable product on the market but when
we're telling people not to flush
anything there's a huge incentive to the
industry to have a standard that's
enforceable that's standard across
multiple States or hopefully every state
eventually uh so the consumers know what
to buy and not to buy and how to
properly dispose of it thank
you any other questions from the
committee yeah and I can answer one of
the previous questions if I may sure um
somebody asked the approximate cost to a
utility uh there's a National
Organization that did a study and they
came up about $30,000 per utility so you
could pick you know a larger utility
might be more a smaller one might be a
little less but the results of their
study was $330,000 additional costs a
year uh due to these materials at the
moment representative
dudy thank you for taking my question um
is the does dees see any cost involved
in terms of enforcement if a law should
become uh if a bill should become
law yeah I have it depends on what the
law would be and how it would be and who
would enforce it um I I can't answer
that question right now I need more
information okay but if there's an
enforcement part of the bill Dees would
most likely be charged with that is that
correct I can't answer that at the
moment either cuz I heard there was
another agency that might get involved
with labeling of products and uh I just
connected with one of the Wastewater
operators of another facility and I
think that would take more exploration
as well to determine who you know the
best Agency for enforcement would be and
uh all of that so I mean there would be
a cost for staff time to go out and do
it if Dees was chosen and you know we
were the lead Agency on that but without
knowing what the legislation would read
we want to just study it and come up
with some good recommendations at the
moment thank you representative VI yes
uh we thank you for taking my question
we asked this question of a couple of
the representatives but as someone who
would potentially be on the commission
if it's a commission and on a and
testifying before a committee if it were
a committee uh do you what do you see as
the advantages or disadvantages of doing
this as a commission
or
being the commission that I could serve
on as a member all this material is part
of like you know an hour display that I
go around educating Wastewater people
all around the state and I would love to
really make sure the members of the
group really understand the issue and
that I can get my information out and I
could learn from others as well to to
more fully understand the issue um
because it it does get quite complex
actually when you get down into it with
all these different products and
labeling and what is good for a sewer
system what is good for a pump what's
good for a septic system so you know to
have some time to examine it I you know
I fully we as Dees fully support the
legislation thank
you thank you thank you any other
questions from the committee no
okay thank you so much for bringing
those visuals it's really
helpful go
ahead okay next up we will have Larry oh
sorry Ma maznik sorry if I get the name
wrong and he uh represents New Hampshire
Ash or
NH
welcome good morning honorable
chairperson Pearl my name is Larry
masnik I am uh representing the New
Hampshire Association of septic hollers
of which I am the active president of
right
now um I'm going to read the uh letter
that Nash had drafted for this uh
hearing the membership of New Hampshire
Association of setic callers feels quite
passionate about the subject of
flushable wipes and the Havoc that they
cause in the municipality Wastewater
collection system in treatment plants
and in private septic
systems or can we say in many Wastewater
systems and many septic systems although
the unfortunate situation of a septic
backup for the average homeowner often
results in emergency to their local
septic Pumper
as a group we recognize the more
important damage and loss it
creates we know that back backups can
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars to
an average
homeowner but can cost Millions to a
municipality which of course we all know
ultimately that the kind of expense gets
passed through to the paying sewer users
both commercial and
residential not to mention the
environmental impact and unhealthy
circumstances as
well we all seen the photos of the big
cities of these super clogs and
monstrous
prorities the cause is real Nash members
would like to log our support for what
HB 1134 seeks to do establishing a study
committee to come forward with a more
effective way of educating the more of
the general
public either sew or septic to combat
around our state and or assist in more
National effort I know this committee
would be a great way to get all these
supportive organizations to the table to
collectively further
research what steps other states have
taken perhaps other states success can
add for Aid in how New Hampshire can
develop a successful outreach program to
our residents
and tourists to the respect of What Not
to flush
mentality we look forward to being a
name part of this
discussion and willing to assist in any
way we
can thank you s that's it that's all all
right any uh any questions from Mr M
representative exp so
um you mentioned the cost of uh
a backup in a homeowner system and
backup in Municipal system is there an
issue when when you have pumped a system
or in the process of pumping a a septic
tank or in the process of taking that
septic tank waste to disposal are there
further issues involved in
that further issues M uh representative
Bixby
I I had one uh I many War stories about
this I can go on I don't want to tie you
folks up forever but I had one in
Bedford New Hampshire this past spring
uh I went out to the ladies septic tank
a septic tank is if you think of it it's
it's just to capture the solids okay
it's supposed to separate the solids
from the waste water the gray
water her tank was so bunged up with
these things she had two daughters
herself
the uh I couldn't break the uh wipes
apart I have I also carry on my truck is
it's a crustbuster it's it looks like an
ice AA with a prop on the end and I
could not get through this we had to I
had
to I had to have her go to uh uh bellore
septic and and drain they do the drains
on the sides of the highways is a very
expensive unit but she's and her her
rort to me was they all say they're
flushable that costs her some money and
you know what happens is it clogs in
there so hard water can't go out that
outlet baffle and it just backs into the
homes um I've been on many uh occasions
with AAA pump out of Manchester through
nashille and Manchester uh these these
uh pump stations like r was alluding to
you know they have the main streets at
the at the municipality the wastewater
treatment
plant but these neighborhoods that have
these pump stations here and there all
spread out probably all over conquered
also these get backed up and then the
the the effluent the the seage is coming
out onto the street right out of the
manhole covers I've seen them where they
there's so much pressure it pops the
cover right off the thing and it water
just bubbling out by the time I get
there our pump trucks we just empty out
this pump station so the guys can get
down there and work on it and then we
got to stay there to take the oncoming
sewers so until they get those pumps
cleared uh and they pull these pumps out
and they're so wrapped up with these
wipes it it it sometimes it burns the
pumps out even though these pumps are
designed with uh thrashing uh impellers
on them to cut through this type of
stuff it still doesn't do the
job thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you for letting me
speak next up we have Sheila Connelly
from the New Hampshire Water Pollution
Control Association she needs three
minutes good morning and thank you for
taking the time morning um so as you've
heard in just this teeny it's
complicated it's there's not an easy
answer here and we originally when we
thought about uh asking representative
buo to introduce legislation we were
thinking we would actually introduce
language for labeling and it became
apparent very quickly that we were
probably stepping outside of our bounds
relative to the Commerce Clause so um we
said all right let's have a commission
and let's figure this out because the
wastewater treatment plants are just
buried the pandemic hasn't helped
because there's so many people using
these wipes on everything um so I I um I
volunteer for the New Hampshire um Water
Pollution Control Association I've been
a member for all of my professional life
um usually I'm here before you talking
about biosolids because I'm a land
application company here in New
Hampshire and the Northeast but my time
on this um
Association I have to also think about
the impact to our industry and this is
just at a Tipping Point we can't keep up
with it anymore
um Rey mentioned that we're also looking
at the national level with a
organization called Inda and that is
sort of looking at labeling across the
whole country so we want to mirror and
build on what's happening in other parts
of the country and at the federal level
with legislation so um I would just end
with please support this commission I do
think it's very important the members
that we've put together all bring
different stories you know New Hampshire
Municipal Association the Bia our group
rural state so all of these folks have a
a a vested interest and a lot of
information to bring but it's going to
take some time it is complicated and if
I could just have one mission in life it
would be the three PS that's all you
flush PE poop and
paper that's not reality we got a lot of
work to do and I hope you will support
this um study
commission thank you will you take
questions yes representative Aaron thank
you thank you so much for your testimony
today my question is um labeling is is
great a great idea a great place to
start what would you foresee possibly to
do in the way of public education yes
because that's a big key too I mean it
it's one thing for you to see something
on a label
but what's your thoughts on that so
that's part of it and that's part of
what the legislation looks to do is to
figure out better ways for Dees and its
Partners to do public education and
Outreach Ray Gordon has actually done a
ton of it for years um but the wipes
piece has grown exponentially it is a
billion dooll business and that's really
what it's coming to so between wipes and
fat when people put grease down the
drain we literally get fatbergs and it's
the grease congealing with all the wipes
it's incredible so it's this is not a
single answer it's a many pronged
approach but this is an important place
for the conversation to start and raise
the level of concern and the legislature
is the place to do it thank you
yep any other
questions thank you for your time seeing
none
thanks all right our final card that I
have is Christina Dublin from the Surf
Rider Foundation New Hampshire chapter
and she's requesting three
minutes welcome thank you uh good
morning chair Pearl Vice chair Aaron and
distinguished members of the committee
my name is Christina Dubin I live in
Portsmith and I'm here today as a
volunteer from the surf riter Foundation
New Hampshire chapter to speak in strong
support of HB
1134 um our foundation is an activist
Network dedicated to the protection and
enjoyment of the world's oceans waves
and beaches for all people by engaging
in plastic reduction ocean protection uh
beach access Coastal preservation and
clean water efforts so our chapter's
Beach uh cleanup data demonstrates that
throughout the continuing pandemic
consumers have significantly increased
the use of disposable wipes as you've
heard we find them littered on our
beaches and waterways at rates much
higher than in Pre pandemic times but we
know that this problem is more than what
we're seeing on the beaches mislabeled
wipes are being contested by Wastewater
officials and plaintiffs who have
brought class action lawsuits against
white
manufacturers Plus ing products other
than toilet paper can cause sewers we
water treatment plants and septic
systems to fail because these systems as
it's been said were not designed to
handle these materials and these
failures Co um result in costly repairs
for homeowners businesses
municipalities uh and the state New York
City has spent more than 18 million over
five years to repair equipment and
problems because of this very issue
additionally the discharges from
overflow can cause Raw and partially
treated sewage to seep into our Coastal
watersheds polluting local waterways and
putting drinking water and Public Health
at
risk many misleadingly labeled flushable
products also contain plastic fibers
which can break down into microplastics
and ultimately these end up in the
environment because sanitation
facilities and septic systems cannot
remove them and the problem is getting
so bad that the EPA issued an
announcement reinforcing the importance
of only flushing toilet paper down the
toilet current attempts at public
education and voluntary manufacturer
labeling are just not working um
inconsistencies and mislabeling have
clearly led to mass confusion about
what's flushable and what is not and
this is why several states have started
taking action the state of Washington
passed along March 2020 that requires do
not flush logos on non- flushable wipes
and similar bills have surfaced in
California and Minnesota but this
problem as we've heard is not just out
west it's in New England and it's here
in New Hampshire and it's an issue that
needs our protection to protect our
watersheds our Wastewater systems and
our pockets so we urge you to vote this
favorably out of committee um to help
New Hampshire just study this labeling
issue and its direct impacts to our
state I did submit uh my regional chair
Melissa Gates uh did submit written
testimony that has citations and more
in-depth information um and I thank you
for your time and I'm happy to try to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you any questions from Miss
do I think you're going to have an easy
time on the questions thank you is there
anybody else that would like to speak on
House Bill
1134 all right seeing none could we uh
pass the blue sheet
up
okay we have one four people signed in
all in
favor with that I will close the hearing
on House Bill
1134 we'll uh open up House Bill 1420 in
about five minutes at
11 excuse me at
10:45
e
for
just
back
than
espe coming up
your
all right being 11:45 we are going
to open up uh House Bill 1420
prohibiting the issuance of new
landfill uh excuse
me being 1045 not 11:45 we're going to
open up House Bill 1420 prohibiting the
issuance of new landfill permits until
the state Solid Waste plan is updated
and I will call on representative mamila
to introduce the
bill
thank you Mr
chairman thank you esteemed
colleagues um for the record I am
representative Linda
Massa and I represent Grafton
one Among Us
States New Hampshire is the fifth
smallest state
geographically and yet since 200
15 between 46 and 50% of our landfill
waste comes from out of
state which then reduces New Hampshire's
capacity for instate
waste so House Bill 1420 may help to
address problems like this by updating
our state's Solid Waste Management
plan let me give you a brief
timeline 1996 New Hampshire revised the
state Solid Waste Management plan law
rather to expressly state that it is the
purpose of the law to quote protect
human health to preserve the natural
environment and conserve precious and
dwindling natural resources through the
proper and integrated management of
solid waste end
quote 20 and three RSA 149
dm29 said mandatory duties for New
Hampshire set new mandatory duties for
New Hampshire's Department of
Environmental Services which was to
publish a state Solid Waste plan every
six years for use in guiding its review
of permanent of permit application and
permit making
decisions New Hampshire Dees last
prepared a state Solid Waste plan in
2003 and has not been in compliance with
RSA 49-
m29 for 18 years because as Dees cited
they are underst
staffed
underfunded and I would assume when a
workload is high and
overwhelming strategic planning is a low
priority and personally side I think
maybe as legislators we should look at
helping de with funding and with
Staffing since they are so
overwhelmed um in
2021 the legislate legislature
acknowledged the importance of a solid
waste plan by amending the new law with
hb4
413 requiring Dees to publish an update
plan with the help of the newly formed
New Hampshire Solid Waste working group
that decision reflected a clear
understanding that a current updated
Solid Waste plan is important to the
Department's ability to carry out the
requirements the policies and the
objectives of the solid waste management
law which serves to guide New Hampshire
Dees through its permitting process for
landfill
capacity the revised w reduction goals
as stated in House Bill
413 require the reduction of the
quantity of solid waste
disposed by
20% 25% in the year 2030 and by
45% in the year
2050 New Hampshire
Dees last prepared a state Solid Waste
plan in
2003 and it has not been in compliance
as I mentioned
before with an outdated Solid Waste plan
there have been some resulting
consequences the state has failed to
achieve its waste reduction goals and
according to New Hampshire Business
Review in a 2020 report waste disposal
in New Hampshire
increased
21% since
2015 the state has been unable TR to
transition away from lean filling to
statuto prefer preferred
methods such as Source reduction Reuse
Recycling and
incineration so why is updating
important
because Solid Waste capacity needs
change as a function of population
change progress with recycling programs
consumer Trends it's also important
solid because Solid Waste technology
evolves and lots of changes in the solid
waste market and consumer preferences
have surfaced since
2003 in conclusion usion since Dees
recognizes that their plan is outdated
and the solid waste working group is
working on a solid waste plan I see
House Bill
1420 as a way to help jumpstart the
process thank
you will you take any questions sure
there any questions for M
Miller seeing none I guess you won't
have to thank you thank you very much
thank
you okay next up we will have uh John
Swan from Save Forest Lake and he's
requesting five
minutes good morning Mr chairman
committee thank you for hearing my
testimony my name is John Swan I'm the
founder of save Forest Lake um kind of
hate to say it I'm
sick and tired of coming before this
committee this is year three now in our
fight to uh in essence not only stop an
un unnecessary unwanted landfill up in
the north country but since then we've
really paid a lot of attention to State
solid waste policy and practice and we
see that there's there's a lot of flaws
a lot of shortcomings in what's taking
place I think that's why you're seeing
today and probably uh in the up and
coming weeks uh legislation a lot of
environmentally related legislation it's
all related uh not only Solid Waste uh
recycling
Posas I mean
basically landfilling is at is at the
bottom of the solid waste hierarchy and
for good reason and so House Bill 1420
which I support and I urge you to
support it as ought to pass as amended
because we are seeking
to prevent prohibit New Hampshire Dees
from permitting a new landfill which
again would be at the bottom of the
waste hierarchy and for good reason why
permit a potential mistake with the
solid waste working group updating the
solid waste plan which as representative
Milla stated is outdated it's
expired 2003 it's expired out of date as
of 2010
so I ask you this what other entity in
New Hampshire is allowed to in essence
be Exempted from the state rsas that
require it to update its licensing every
six years Dees has opted not to instead
they've chosen to focus on permitting
and Regulation and admittedly they're
underst staffed under
budgeted but at the same time why should
they be allowed to issue a new landfill
permit which could run contrary to the
waste diversion goals of our state
that's why we're here that's why you're
going to hear about a bottle bill later
on again we we've met with our
legislators to propose legislation to
help you I've spent three years every
day this is my full-time job just
researching and reading going through
dees1 stop I mean I do this I I go I've
been to all the solid waste working
group meetings I go to the waste
management Council meetings because I
want to educate myself on what's going
on in the state and how we can help
protect our natural environment our
precious resources from being further
exploited particularly by outof state
companies that plague our state with
incoming out ofst State trash so I I'm
not going to belabor the point all I'm
asking you to do is support House Bill
1420 as amended uh because we are
excluding despite the language of um OS
and Dees uh we don't feel expansions of
existing landfills should apply we're
not here to cause disruptions in solid
waste matters but we want to help
address problems and shortcomings and
right now the state Solid Waste plan
which is a road map it's a road map to
guide Dees in determining public benefit
for new landfills until the state Solid
Waste plan is updated whether it's in
2022 which I don't believe is going to
happen because Solid Waste working
groups got a lot of work ahead of them
if that's going to happen but by
2026 so why allow Dees to permit a
mistake that our state's going to have
to live with and it's not only in Dalton
it could be wherever Waste Management
chooses its next landfill because look
at us today it's deja vu all over again
these problems were brought forth in the
'90s
in early 2000 and guess what here we are
all over again doing it again so please
all we're asking for is a new paragraph
in RSA 149 M just basically requiring
Dees or prohibiting Dees from permitting
a new landfill until the solid waste
plan has been updated and is consistent
with the requirements of RSA 149
m29 thank you thank you for your
testimony will you take any questions I
definitely will are there any questions
for Mr
Swan representative perz thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my my
question do you believe that this bill
will help us to uh get hit the goal that
at 3030 goal to uh conserve L 30% of
land and 30% of Water by
2030 well I say if if the waste plan is
not updated definitely not so um I
believe that uh look at the 2003 Solid
Waste plan it is not met those goals of
40% waste reduction for the state in
fact waste has increased both within the
state generated waste and out of state
waste coming into our borders we have a
trash problem so I would say this would
help at least put Dees on notice that
they can't allow
this this uh to not updated for another
20 years or however many years it's
going to be the solid waste working
group now is is calling for according to
House Bill 413 a 10-year um period to
update the the waste plan but as stated
previously the waste plan is a road map
this is like taking a a road trip across
the country with a GPS from 2003 that
hasn't been updated would you feel
pretty confident in taking that trip I
mean it's a road map so answer your
question I'd say this would help thank
you thank you any other questions from
Mr
Swan seeing done thank you for your
testimony thank
you next we'll have uh Wayne Morrison
from NC ABC and he's asking for five
minutes good morning good morning uh my
testimony was uh submitted
electronically I have hard copies here
if anybody wants them but it's already
been
submitted um good morning chairman Pearl
and members of the
committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to testify here today for
the record my name is Wayne Morrison and
I'm a resident of Whitefield and I'm
also here today as president of North
Country Alliance for balance change to
speak in support of House Bill
1420 ncbc is a Grassroots nonprofit
organization whose mission is balancing
the natural resources and economic
interests in New Hampshire's North
Country it is through that advocacy work
that we have recognized the urgent need
for solid waste reform to protect the
health safety and environmental
interests of citizens not only in the
North country but throughout the
state We Believe House Bill 1420 is a
smart simple and Common Sense bill that
prohibits the issuance of permits for
any newly constructed landfills until
the state's Solid Waste plan has been
updated last year the house took the
critically important step of passing
house bill 14 413 establishing a solid
waste working group and creating clear
and measurable Solid Waste reduction
goals the solid waste working group is
also charted with assisting de s and
updating the state's Solid Waste
plan as you well know CH chairman Pearl
that work is now in
process the reason why House Bill 1420
is needed is that the state has operated
without benefit of an updated plan for
nearly two
decades in the absence of an updated
plan there have been
consequences clear and me measurable
waste reduction goals have not been
established or mon
nor have metrics been available to drive
corrective actions or modification to
the state's permanent and Regulatory
policies in the absence of a current
plan the state has not realized the
potential of implementing policies that
more fully support the solid waste
hierarchy thus reducing the Reliance on
landfilling in favor of more desirable
practices such as Source reduction
Recycling and reuse and comp and
composting to our detriment landfilling
remains today the deao
standard the lack of an updated Solid
Waste plan has also contribut
contributed greatly to the state's
lagging position relative to its New
England
neighbors while other states have
tightened regulations closed landfills
and reduced landfill capacity New
Hampshire has become a more favored
destination for importing there
out of state
trash without an updated plan and a
coherent
strategy this trend is only likely to
accelerate to the extent that there is a
landfill capacity pressure in New
Hampshire it is in large measure driven
by the importation of outof State trash
that now consumes nearly 50% of our
available landfill
capacity a landfill
permit is a generational decision with
enormous health safety and environmental
impacts and risks for decades to
come landfills are never a one andone
and once started there is inevitably
going to be
expansions for example the landfill
proposed in Dalton would have about a
38-year life the expectations would be
beyond that life there would be
expansions we could be living in a
hypothetical example for the ne the
nearly The Next Century with a decision
that would be permanent without the
benefit of a solid waste
plan certainly such a a decision of such
magnitude should be made in the context
of the latest plans goals and objectives
at the state's
disposal we urge you to support and pass
host Bill
1420 to ensure the State's permitting
and Regulatory policies will reflect the
state's updated Solid Waste plans and
goals before permits of newly
constructed landfills are
issued thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to provide testimony today
and I would be happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions
yes I was reviewing the uh Solid Waste
plan of uh 2003 last night and I was
amazed at the fact that almost none of
it has been
implemented um I thought it was a very
good plan I see things like number two
manufacturers must subscribe to product
stewardship and take responsibility for
their role in Source reduction which is
what we've talked about today I see
things that there was a
40% um goal of Source reduction in 2000
and we didn't even meet it then it was
by
24% so my question is is if we have a
plan from
2003 that could really be used in two 20
2022 what makes us think that having a
new plan is going to make any difference
in terms of what uh the Department of
Environmental Services actually does
because this plan apparently wasn't
followed yeah I I should start thank
thank you for the question I should
start by saying we're not here to point
a finger at the state at Dees at any
individuals we recognize there's a
problem and there's a bunch of
contributors to that problem we come
here prepared to work with the committee
recognizing that this problem existed
back in 2003 and it has only gotten
worse my understanding part of the
reason that it wasn't implemented is
there was difficulties in actually
quantifying the metrics how how you came
up with the 40%
reduction part of House Bill 413 made it
much more easy to recognize what we're
going to reduce uh by 30% by a certain
year the total amount of of of waste and
and therefore I think in any in any
business I spent my I spent a 40-year
career working for large companies in
the technology
field somebody asked earlier you know um
H how not only how would this work but
you know what's the importance of a plan
well it may it may or not work but we
know if you don't start the the working
group grappling with the problem coming
up with priorities trying to establish
critical things that we need to focus on
is the first step in a lot of things
that we have to do the fact that the the
plan was put into law and then basically
ignored for two decades says it wasn't a
priority to anybody no nobody pushed
back on you know I don't know who shot
who we're not here for that all I know
is the start of getting well is get get
a new plan updated commit to it and in
an any in any activity have have us be
accountable for the results and use the
data that we get to make midcourse
Corrections and try and see if we can
reverse some of the trends that as a
state and as Citizens in the state we
clearly do not like we don't like where
we are let's work on how do we get to a
better place and that's what we think
the first step is getting this bill
passed and getting focused and taking
the the good work that's going to be
done by the working committee and trying
to put it into place and and start from
there any other
questions all right seeing none we thank
you for your testimony thank you very
much next we will call on Fred Anderson
who's representing himself he's looking
for three
minutes thank you
chairman and thank you members of the
committee for this opportunity to give
testimony on 1420 as I urge you to vote
ought to
pass I'm highly encouraged by by the way
the state legislature is responding to
the need for stronger action requiring
reduction and management of waste in the
state especially establishing criteria
for the safe and proper sighting of
future
landfills three years ago I knew very
little bit about about trash I attended
the very same meeting that many of you
went to that was put on by the
legislature to familiarize you with what
the problems were
for the last three years I've been
meeting before you to talk about this it
began with a landfill in Dalton and we
all learn this is about far more than a
landfill in dalon this is about a real
crisis in the state of New Hampshire the
state's current Waste Management plan is
RO fully out of date as we've all said
delinquent for some 19 years we're not
here to beat up on anyone about that
we're here to say somebody needs to be
ringing the
firebell it's a little bit like deciding
you have to have surgery and going to a
surgeon who hasn't had his license
renewed in 19 years why would you do
that or perhaps an analogy that's a
little bit more appropriate is trying to
deal with
covid-19 with 2003 medical standards so
we're urging you to bring forth this to
begin the process of creating a plan for
the state that will begin to address our
problems it's something everyone is now
aware of a group of us were talking
about this the other day and where we
started most folks thought oh this is
just not my backyard issue well you know
what the whole state is our backyard and
we need to take care of it and to
representative Duffy your question I
think until somebody shuts down the
process nobody's going to start paying
attention I worked in another field for
years and not for profit and I found out
that committees would study things to
death kick the can down the road you
have to put some kind of a barrier in
the way for people to make decisions and
so we're depending upon you to help us
do that we're depending upon you to
represent the people of this state in
terms of dealing with this crisis so we
urge you vote Yes on this bill and thank
you for your attention and most of all
thank you for your service to the people
of New Hampshire I'll be glad to take
questions sir thank you for your
testimony are there any questions from
Mr
Anderson seeing none thank thank you for
coming in to
me uh next up we'll have uh Bob Magnuson
from Waste
Management
well good
morning my name is Bob Magnuson I'm a
lifelong resident of New Hampshire and
I've worked for Waste Management um for
about um over the last 26 years
primarily in New England Massachusetts
and more recently for the last 10 years
or so in uh in New Hampshire um Waste
Management
operates uh we do operate a landfill in
Rochester New Hampshire as well of
another a number of other supporting
operations including waste collection
Transportation uh recycling um that
support um many thousands of customers
in U in New Hampshire um I'm here today
to speak in opposition of this uh bill
is is proposed bill as it's written um
we do support the update that's been
talked about um that is a road map and a
guide those are some of the words that
have been used and those are certainly
need to be remembered as whenever you go
through a process like this um there are
definitely many many factors that play
into this um we never
Advocate absolute Interruption of
services because that can have
tremendous impacts on a whole variety of
things from public health to obviously
obviously the economy um as I read this
this talks about an act prohibiting the
issuance of new landfill permits under
the state's
Solid Waste until the solid state Solid
Waste plan is
updated please keep in mind that
existing landfills are regularly
obtaining obtaining new permits a
landfill is built in phases much like uh
say a residential subdivision might be
constructed over a number of years in a
number of phases landfills um are
constructed and operated in the same
way so uh anything that interrupts that
regular permitting uh which many facil
ities um our facility for one as well as
I'm sure other facilities in New
Hampshire are obtaining new permits on a
regular basis and there's some uh the
way that is read way that is written is
some concern for us seems like this is
directed at landfills specifically new
landfills but within the text of the
proposed language it uses the term
facility which by definition in the
statute and the solid waste regulations
that can include other Solid Waste facil
as well transfer station recycling
facilities composting facilities and and
other alternative technology facilities
so again while this appears to be
directed towards the landfills uh
towards new
landfills there is uh I pulled a
sentence out of the proposed House Bill
1454 that would be acceptable to us that
would be tied into this that sentence
reads nothing in this paragraph shall be
construed to prohibit the expansion of
any landf bills that are in
operation at the time this act takes
effect and again that was uh I pulled
that out of house bill 1454 as it's
drafted right now which is going to be
heard later today so with that um that's
all the testimony that I had today thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there any uh questions representative
Bixby thank you for taking my question
the um the prime SP sponsor of uh this
bill uh has Cate has done an amendment
that changes the wording uh from new fa
uh uh permit for construction of a new
facility to permit for the construction
of a new
landfill
uh excluding the expansion of existing
landfills so uh would you be in favor of
that
change yeah I think I would have to see
that in its entirety I think I follow
what you're saying but uh I haven't seen
that as it's as you described
it well perhaps we'll let let Mr
Magnuson have a chance to read and
digest that before we try and put him to
a
position there any further questions
from Mr
Magnuson from the
committee we'll give you an opportunity
to take a look at that and
per unless there something you want to
say right away yeah I would think I my
only comment would be is to this this
would need to be followed
through um to see how this links and
continues down within the RSA 149 m29 as
it's
mentioned
um you need to be careful to avoid kind
of this do Loop type of thing where you
do this before that but you can't do
this before that and you haven't really
accomplished anything so just I would
Reserve whether that would be accept I
would need to kind of Follow that
through for the rest of the RSA to see
how that fits
in any further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you he next up we have Michael fer from
the town of Meredith looking for five
minutes thank you Mr chair member of the
committee my name is Michael Fowler I'm
the Public Works director in the town of
Meredith been there 24 years
um it's part of the New Hampshire
Vermont Solid Waste project which
dissolved in
2007 set on the executive committee
executive board for Northeast resource
recovery Association was the vice
president for a few
years um I'm in opposition of the bill
the way it's written I did hear that we
have an amendment on on the floor I
understand how that is going um I'm here
to speak specifically as our transfer
station in
Meredith um the way the bill is
currently written if I need to amend
that permit or do something different I
feel that this would restrict
us um I understand there was legislation
back in
2003 to create Dees uh have New
Hampshire Dees come up with a new plan
every six years I can't speak to that
either um but I do know there's been
legislation passed and things haven't
been followed
um if there was some sort of you know we
as a municipality our hands are tied we
get the trash I have to deal with it um
when I took over in 97 we were doing
about $65,000 a year in
recyclables I boosted that in the early
2000s close to 400
,000 right now it's backed down I'm
barely making any money because of
Transportation costs recyclable markets
have tanked um it's getting harder and
harder to find the end game to move it
that's the real question what are we
going to do with it when we get
it
um I find that being extremely difficult
and I've scratched my head for 24 years
and it's gotten real bad this 40%
reduction that we're looking at by 2030
or whenever the dates were I don't have
it written down but I can tell you in
the 24 years Meredith and Center Harbor
in The Lakes Region have grown
immensely um especially in the last 18
months 65% predominantly second
homes um to see lights on in January
February
247 where those houses were barely used
3 weeks a year
um everyone's up here they don't take
their trash home they drop it off at our
facility my trash is up 25
30% um mixed paper I was getting 38
bucks a ton five years ago it was
costing me a hundred two years ago to
get rid of it what do you do we have to
deal with it once it comes to our
facility we have to deal with it I
understand the North country is faced
with some difficult challenges I have
compassion for that I'm not here to talk
what they need to do on that um I
understand this might be a an Avenue to
help um but I think if there can be
tailored where a municipal landfills or
transfer facilities that are currently
running um are Exempted I don't know if
it's the right thing to do to tie it and
put it all on New Hampshire de's back um
I don't know know what the right answer
is but I do know I have to manage the
trash that comes into my facility daily
we're open six days a week I have to get
it
somewhere so I leave you with that um I
thank the board and the committee here
for allowing me to speak for my
testimony will you take any questions
sure are there any questions from Mr
Waller representative
Duty um I've heard that argument before
regarding Recycling and that uh the
revenue stream isn't there like it used
to be you know in in years past but do
people in your position ever consider
the opportunity cost of not recycling in
other words if you don't recycle okay
even if you have to pay to get rid of it
you still have to do some it doesn't
evaporate you still have to do something
with it and haven't and because
landfills are so huge I've I've seen the
land expansion that we have in
nashwa um I mean it
covers covers my entire
neighborhood um isn't there a cost to
that also
absolutely ever take that into
consideration though uh we have um but
uh back even prior to my start the
selectman opted to run a transfer
facility and there's a town ordinance
that's requires 100% mandatory recycling
we do not do curbside
pickup we have a facility that's
run where it's um user based you come in
with your recyclables you throw out your
trash you throw out your Plastics we
recycle everything and we Market that
and we predominantly use Northeast
resource recovery Association where we
can um to give them the business as well
as we do go through some local haulers
and I think uh we try to do as much
local as we can to keep our local guys
moving
um there is with every action there's a
reaction and it it's just the way of
life um we have to manage that and to
sit here and say we're not going to
recycle I look at it
as if that is not going to the landfill
and I can recycle it recycle it and it's
costing a little bit of
money
it's not going into a landfill so we're
saving
space um I'm saving space in New
Hampshire our trash goes to New
Hampshire that that's my goal is to keep
New Hampshire's base allocated for New
Hampshire I I think that's the way we
should look at it I know there's laws
out there that prohibit certain uh
intercommerce stuff and I can't
articulate those those laws but perhaps
maybe we should start there and see what
really needs to be done to maybe limit
some trash coming in I don't have those
answers I worry about what this is going
to do to Meredith and Santa Harbor and
possibly tie my hands and that's what
I'm concerned with so thank
you thank
you new landfill instead of facility
representative Murray a question I do
thank you chairman for allowing me to
make a question hi thank you thank you I
have a brief um question the New
Hampshire legislature has recently been
focused on composting regulations what
if any thoughts do you have around that
as far as uh one Avenue for Waste
reduction it's I think it's a great
waste reduction my wife and I did a
project this
summer and we actually pulled all house
food waste out of our trash we were
diligent all summer and it was amazing
the amount of trash that was built up in
compost the problem that I see and I
don't have all the answers but there was
a gentleman in Maine I think it's Elliot
that started a composting thing lives in
New Hampshire but started it in Maine
because Maine's laws are far less
restrictive on the composting than it is
in New Hampshire
um I think we really need to take a look
at if we're trying to do this and do was
waste reduction we need to look at it
all and we need to look at what laws are
in place prohibiting certain things um
and maybe that needs to be relaxed but I
can tell you New Hampshire isn't getting
any smaller there's more and more people
coming tourism is going through the roof
because people want clean and fresh air
they're leaving the cities so what's
that
mean more
trash so that 40% is based on 2000
numbers or is it based on 2025 numbers
um because we're already 40% over what
what we were back
then but I totally believe composting is
a helpful way to
reduce um Municipal Solid
Waste sorry viby I thank you for taking
my question um so uh in 2015 we actually
did change that law and in 20 just this
fall the department of uh uh Dees uh
came out with a proposed rule for
dealing uh for making it easier to deal
with composting and I'm not quite sure
when that's going to be finalized but it
should be I'm I'm hoping it will be
finalized fairly soon once that's in
place is composting something that your
facility would be able to work with on a
municipal
level I think it's something we're going
to have to consider my problem is
space um limited space um that's what
I'm dealing with now and then where do I
take it once it comes into my facility
what do I do with it um it's great to
say you need the
compost but what do I do with it um same
thing with glass I mean I was working
with Northeast Source recovery we trying
to find homes for glass um right now I
was crushing it up I was using it under
my roads and gravels and drainage great
use for it look at those
laws with an hdes that's pretty
restrictive so great use for it what I
think glass should be used for great
great use for septic systems depending
the process but that's a whole another
topic that we could spend hours on but
it's nice to hear that there has been
some uh review of that law and hopefully
it's going to be
um less restrictive and uh maybe we can
get some people in the state to start
doing some uh
composting all right well we thank you
for your testimony uh repa could you
send the blue sheet for this bill in
this direction as we're going on to our
last speaker uh next we'll have uh
director whimet from New Hampshire
Dees I'll just make a brief statement
too for anyone who has submitted or has
given testimony and has not given me
their paper copy to please do so to
representative Homa thank
you good morning uh again it's Mike
whimet I serve as director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Dees and I appreciate the opportunity to
testify on House Bill
1420 uh as before um I I had not I now
have seen the proposed amendment that
has been put forth but my letter of
testimony which was shared
electronically and is now being
distributed on paper is based on the
original bill is introduced so I'll I'll
be very brief
just just so I can summarize that that
testimony the main we're not taking a
position on this bill we did have a
concern that we thought we should share
with the committee and that concern is
largely in the introduced version of the
bill as others have suggested the term
new facility is a very broad term that
would capture I think and I don't think
it was the intent of the sponsor that
would capture um any kind of facility
any new facility whether it be a um
recycling facility or a transfer station
or a Compost Facility and we we do
actually have a couple of pending
applications in that category we would
likely make a decision on before October
1 of 22 which is the deadline for uh
completing a new state solid waste plans
so if this were a pass is introduced it
would have an impact we would be unable
to approve permits for those facilities
um it it is also the case that uh a new
facility includes an expansion of an
existing landfill as has been discussed
so I'll leave that since that's been
discussed at some length uh first of all
I want to make it clear we intend we
have a responsibility to prepare an
update to the state Solid Waste plan by
October one of this year we intend to
meet that
deadline um so basically if the the new
Amendment were to be taken up by the
committee and and and passed essentially
as I understand this new Amendment it
would only apply to new Solid Waste
landfills a green fields development of
a solid waste landfill um again I would
expect that we I fully anticipate we
will have an updated State Solid Waste
plan um by October 1 of 2022 and we
would expect to be able to render any
decisions on any pending applications
following that um I I it's looking quite
a ways ahead assuming that that plan is
approved in October it would be en force
and for 10 years it would not be due to
be updated for 10 years under the under
the law I don't expect I'll be involved
in this business at that time however um
if uh the department for some reason
we're unable to meet the deadline 10
years from now it would create a sit
situation where they would be unable to
uh render a decision there is a
possibility not knowing why that might
happen or if that could happen there
would be a possibility that it could
create a capacity problem 10 years out
as a result of them not under the
provisions of this bill as as suggested
uh to be in a position not to render a
decision so that's just something I
think for the committee to consider
again the agency is not taking a
position on this bill and I'll leave it
at that I'll be happy to answer any
questions thank you director uh would
would you discuss a little bit uh some
of the challenges that that you've had
with you know we've had a lot of
discussion about the waste reduction
goals that weren't met perhaps you I
know sure I sit on the solid waste
working group so I had the benefit of
hearing some of this but could you just
maybe give the committee a little bit of
background on some of the challenges
that you had with the as it relates to
reporting and understanding exactly what
you were receiving for waste and as far
as attaining these goals right so the
original uh reduction goal that was set
out in the statute uh was was a it goes
back prior to 2000 and it essentially
suggested that uh the goal should be to
reduce to increase recycling rates to
40% or diversion rates to 40% by the
year 2000 um that posed a couple of
problems one is that the agency while it
can do a lot of things through its
permitting processes it's not able to
control EX exactly how waste is
generated or managed in the state that
is something that in essence goes down
to individual generators of the waste
and whatever the market is providing for
services um it also the second part of
the problem is was very difficult to
measure that and it was not defined well
um and depending on how you define it
I've seen uh very uh uh convincing
arguments that we did achieve a 40%
diversion rate if you define it more
stringently there's convin arguments
that we never came close to it so and
and everywhere in between so in the last
couple sessions of the legislature there
was a lot of discussion about that and
the new and they've been discussed by
others here the new reduction goal was
put in place um Senator Waters bill um
establish that and that is a much more
measurable um and easier to U uh
confirm uh standard and so those those
goals have been set looking into the
future and we would expect that our
state Solid Waste plan um will will
reflect on those and and establish goals
and and plans to to achieve those um but
up until now um up until the time that
bill was changed or that law was changed
we were dealing with this 40% reduction
goal which was outdated because it was
it was a goal that was set to be
achieved you know 20 years ago I don't
know if I've answered your question but
that's yeah that's fine I just wanted
the committee to have the benefit of a
little of the information that we had
received at the working
are there any questions representative
Bixby yes uh you mentioned that you were
uncomfortable with the uh possibility
that uh as we approach uh
2031 this law might uh create problems
for permitting at that point uh would
you uh if we were to put in a sunset
that would be triggered by the uh by the
publication of the uh plan that's due
out in October of this year uh would
that help resolve that
issue uh again I'm not sure I said I was
uncomfortable with it I simply raised it
to the Committees to to be to make sure
the committee understood that as I read
the bill um as Dees interprets this
that's the impact that it would have
right but but but if we put a sunset in
would that resolve that issue I think
what it would mean then is that the bill
would really only have effect for you
know the next six months okay un unless
assuming that the plan goes in on time
as I said we intend to meet that
deadline so um May I follow up yes uh so
uh there I had mentioned in a previous
question uh whether that there the
composting regulations were in process
could you update us on uh where those
stand sure thank you for that question
actually those are are slated to go
before the joint legislative committee
on min ative rules go back to them in in
in February there were some concerns
raised by the office of legislative
Services which were minor and we're
working those out and we fully expect to
be before the jail car um in February
thank
you representative
amola thank you hi there I have uh one
question for you with regard to the
solid waste plan you had mentioned that
it's potentially being drafted or it's
in process now and you anticipate
October is that correct that's correct
we have a clear directive to complete
one by October 1 of this year um there's
also a directive that the state Solid
Waste working group which has been
convened by um rep under representative
eiles bill um starting this fall uh
we're working in Earnest with them
they've already had two meetings they've
got another meeting in February and
we'll be taking input and working with
uh with that committee on the content
and we expect to to meet the deadline
can I follow up um who approves the the
plan and generally how long does it take
for their
approval there's no formal approval
mechanism for the plan um obviously
we're going to take a lot of guidance
and input from the working group um it
will essentially be a process where we
will um review that draft with the
committee um or with the working group
take public comment we intend to take
public comment on the plan and then uh
following review of that comment and any
further committee input we would publish
the plan okay thank you sure
representative
dsy thank you for taking my question um
I'm looking at the
2003 Solid Waste Management plan and
under goal four uh it says with the
lifespan of existing landfill capacity
estimated to last until
2012 and I was wondering if you could
address that and why uh what happened in
the interim so that we didn't run out of
right F capacity in 2012 yes that that
kind of language has been a pet peeve of
mine ever since I started working in
solid waste I'm glad you asked the
question um we have a requirement to do
a public benefit determination when
under the statute whenever we review an
application for a solid waste landfill
and under that we there there are very
specific Provisions regarding um
determining in order to make a positive
public benefit determination we need to
determine that the proposed facility
will meet some met capacity need and in
the process of doing that we are really
not allowed to look at or project new
permitted capacity that will happen in
the future so what we do is we look at
what is permited right now and what's
the operating life of those permitted
facilities and then um for the purpose
of public benefit determination to say
okay we have permited capacity in this
amount for this many years and that's
appropriate and the right way to do
these public benefit determinations
under the statute
but the reason it's a little bit of a
pet pee for me is that kind of language
and discussion found its way into
countless legislative testimony letters
and and reports like the state plan and
it's misleading because it makes it
sound like okay after 2012 there will be
no permitt there'll be no landfill
capacity in the state and we're all
going to have to figure out something
else to do with our trash and of course
that wasn't true um and and as a result
I I tried to wash that kind of um
discussion from our Communications with
the legisl with the public because it's
misleading it has a very specific
purpose in the context of making a
public benefit determination when we're
making a permit decision but it's not a
good way to communicate with people
about the current status of of landfill
capacity any further
questions right seeing none so U that's
all the cards that I have is there
anyone else that wishes to
testify I see none I'm going to read the
blue sheet we have six people responding
four opposed two in favor and with that
we will close the uh hearing on House
Bill
1420 and we're going to open up the
hearing on House Bill uh one 1049 1049
establishing a committee to study
landfill citing criteria and methods for
reducing pressure on landfill capacity
and I will call on representative Aaron
to introduce the
Bill thank you chairman
Pearl and good morning everyone I'm
introducing to you today House Bill 1049
this bill establishes a study committee
to study landfill sighting
criteria we all recognize that landfills
are necessary and that do serve a great
purpose in Waste Management in New
Hampshire concerns about these landfills
and the landfill sighting process has
been raised by many of our constituents
so it was felt that we must take a good
hard look at the statutes and rules Dees
follows and incorporates into landfill
sighting process here in New Hampshire
we have had so much debate on this issue
in the past few years over where
landfill should or should not be placed
that we really need to examine this
topic in detail we also need to take a
good look at what we are putting in
these landfills and how our current
statutes and rules impact environmental
concerns and the public good
additionally we need to examine how we
can reduce the pressures placed on
landfill capacity and how we can
effectively deal with those
pressures all of these are legitimate
concerns and will be addressed by this
study
committee this is a bipartisan bill that
makes good sense and will go a long way
to set meaningful future legislative
policy I hope that we can pass this bill
out of our committee with an OTP
recommendation and I'd be happy to
answer any questions about what I've
outlined outlined in the Bill thank you
representative I'll have one I'll start
with so we've had several bills that
we've heard already which seem to have
similar uh be along the similar lines of
a topic as to what your study committee
that you're proposing would did uh be
possible maybe that you would see some
of the combining of some of these other
bills and some of the information that
we're looking for and there could be
included in your study committee I think
it would make perfect sense to do so
thank you any other questions for
representative
Aaron all right seeing none thank you
thank you we have uh one other card that
has been um sent forwards which is uh
Matt Ley from the forest Society asking
for two
minutes uh good morning thank you Mr
chairman um for the record I'm Matt Ley
I'm the public policy director for the
for society uh so we support um uh House
Bill 1049 uh the written testimony um
that's being handed out also references
our support for the next bill you're
going to hear U House Bill 1454 so but
I'll just be quick you know our interest
um in this bill really stems from you
know the for society's mission to
protect the land protect the Landscapes
uh in our state and you know we won't go
into details but obviously those
resources especially our Water Resources
Forest
resources are really Central to our
economy uh Environmental health and of
course you know the Aesthetics in our
state so you know we view um you know
quite frankly landfills as a really bad
use of our land um and so you know we we
do really strongly feel there's a need
to to look into you know how our state
is dealing with all this trash now you
know we also understand that um you know
as our economy grows and you know people
are move are still moving into New
Hampshire maybe unlike other states um
you know there's going to be a pressure
you know all this trash is still going
to be generated so you know to us just
making this a priority um and by doing
so by passing this bill we think is
going to be very important to the kind
of the long-term strategy about how we
deal with all this trash that's that is
going to be generated so but I'll happy
to take any questions thank you are
there any questions for Mr lady
seeing none thank you we appreciate your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
that would like to testify on this
bill all right I have the blue sheet
here we had seven people sign in five in
support and two
opposed with that we're going to close
the hearing on uh House Bill
1049 and we will reconvene at 1 pm with
House Bill 1454 thank
you
hear about
glass
supp
want
that's
great
keeps
very
exor I wrote so many things
down
was it in
got
will that
I'm G to grab my jacket
Johnny you bring with you just my uh top
yes I hear
that
for
e
hello
wonderful
yeah
all
bull
this is most been around people long
long
wipes right
here
yeah especially nice
day
this is rck B
froma and
this
is
thank you have a great
day
said
he's not
there no that's who I
call now
also
okay so that one is
now
right
you
beautiful
yeah exactly
not
now
of
prop
right
start
slpp
for
e
second
good
no
spe
you want a hand that table you can your
phone
in think
would
got to be something Elric for a
long
we
succeeded
good
your
for
how's your
day
you leave
there
you
could
yeah are
you
Happ
now we got to talk
figure
course
for
spe
of
you
head
pi
look
good
we definitely appreciate
you
nice nice definitely let us
know
e
is
like
for
e
[Music]
like to be a little further
away
break
cherry you you
you
I had Heather send me copy of all the
bills coming to our
committee she was
so
for
you
so is there someone who hands out the
testimony
or
yes
ma'am
for
I'd rather wait the
minute
[Music]
for
oh yeah Mr Bix needs one too
probably oh great thank
you
for
okay we're going to uh open up uh House
Bill 1454 relative to permits for the
sighting of landfills and I will
recognize representative Tucker to
introduce the Bill thank you for coming
today thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for the committee for most of you
being here many of you being here I'm
representative Edith Tucker Coos 5 tell
me if I'm speaking too loudly or Too
Close I represent the towns of white
Jefferson Carol and
Randolph much of the science in my
testimony reflects the knowledge and
research of Dr Adam finle a resident of
Dalton and former member of the EPA
science Advisory Board and OSHA's Chief
scientist in both the Clinton and George
W bush
administrations it also reflects the
work of a bipartisan group of
legislators and citizens who came
together to address the concerns of
those those legislators who in our last
session could not support hb1
177 which was designed to prohibit a new
landfill within two miles of uh New
Hampshire State
Park I'm very pleased and proud to be
able to introduce HB
1454 as an improved way to balance
health and environment mental protection
with the economic and other concerns
some of you brought up last year I
firmly believe that its passage this
session would be a giant step forward
for the Department of Environmental
Services significantly reducing its
costly time commitment to new landfill
projects that are quite obviously not
environmentally sensible and when I say
that I would like to see this in this
session I do mean it and I pledge to you
that I and those who've worked with me
are willing to work hard with a
subcommittee or meetings other meetings
with the committee to work out the
wrinkles that undoubtedly are in the
Bill particularly in section
c this bill is premised on one basic and
indisputable fact there are sensible
places to site landfills and senseless
places to site them the bill requires
one simple inexpensive and verifiable
test at the beginning of the process
that will reveal to an applicant to de
yes to New Hampshire citizens and
communities whether a particular site is
or is not an environmentally safe
sensible place for the one new landfill
New Hampshire might need over the next
40 to 50 years the test involves digging
a few holes estimating the speed at
which the groundwater Flows at that site
and then sighting the landfill so that
it would take at least five years years
for any polluted groundwater to reach
the nearest lake or
river this test is already part of the
all completed applications submitted to
DS so HB 1454 creates no new burden for
developers it merely requires that the
test be done at the outset the bill
would not require Dees to permit every
applicant whose proposed project does
pass the fiveyear test uh that would
only that they don't have to spend time
considering a whole application which is
a costly and lengthy process after it
failed this so-called entrance exam HB
1454 does two simple things first it
asserts that out of all the negatives of
citing a landfill noise truck traffic
odors dust
scavenger Birds by far the most serious
is the essentially irreversible danger
to water that our citizens drink that
our Wildlife lives in and around and on
which our tourism economy here in New
Hampshire depends this bill is designed
to protect our state's lakes and rivers
all across the
state last year as you recall there was
belief that the previous bill was too
directed at one area we have taken care
that into account in the writing of this
bill protecting them from pollution will
also serve to protect the public and
private Wells on which those living near
lakes and rivers
depend second it simply asserts that the
best way to protect a lake or river from
pollution is to site a landfill far
enough away so that we have a fiveyear
window in which to Det detect intercept
and stop any chemical or bacteri related
contamination before it reaches the
precious water on which all life depends
it's inappropriate and dangerous to
build a landfill where groundwater
speeds away towards a lake or river it
is appropriate and safe to locate a
landfill where groundwater happens to
flow very very slowly toward a lake or
river
this bill merely says that an applicant
or potential applicant should find out
early on how close the nearest lake or
river is to what they hope will be a
potential landfill site and whether the
groundwater in that area trickles away
from that location or hurdles towards it
rapidly as house environment and
agriculture committee members uh know
round water can move as slowly as one
foot per year in soils with a high clay
content and or in Bedrock that's not
full of
fractures in contrast groundwater can
move as quickly as 50 feet per day in
soils that are high in gravel or sand
content and in fractured Rock and I
brought with me uh one
sheet that just shows simply how this uh
how this works I don't have a color
printer so it's not in color the way it
should be but I think you'll see that it
teaches you that paracity versus
PR permeability is the what we're trying
to get at here and I think a lot of us
don't think a lot about what's under our
feet I know that farmers and
agricultural people do think a lot about
soils that's why I assume that you all
know this but I hope you not insult that
we go over this a little bit this bill
does not call for a TW mile setback as
did last year's Bill H 177 that I
introduced on a zoom uh platform some
legislators thought that two miles was
an arbitrary one siiz fits-all figure
this year our proposed legislation is
more
science-based the applicant must
estimate the speed at which groundwater
flows away from a particular site so
that it cannot reach the nearest water
body for at least 5 years at that flow
rate HB 1454 would update and modernize
a key number in the state's code of
administrative rules a current 200 foot
one siiz fits-all setback from the New
Hampshire water bodies that's what we're
operating under now that's the one siiz
fits-all that's what's in place Yes you
heard me correctly one size fits all and
that one size is so small a distance
that in porest soil it could allow a
landfill to be cited only two or three
weeks away from seriously polluting a
lake or river it took me a little time
to wrap my head around this thinking
of water and speed and feet and and
that's why I'm sort of going over that a
couple of times because it's a different
for me a different way of thinking of
things furthermore Dees only requires
groundwater monitoring at landfills
every four months or less frequently
because this bill inure ensures the
state's next landfill would not be
located within a few months flow of one
of our state's precious lakes or Rivers
it has the potential to save tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars in
future remediation expenses
that's because all landfills will leak
this is not just the conclusion the EPA
reached in the
1990s but one it continues to believe
today
unfortunately new peer-reviewed studies
support this
conclusion none of the new landfills
around the country built after say the
year 2000 are old enough to have an EST
have an established a real track record
of how long they can go without leaking
we just don't know if they leak after 25
or 50 or 75
years although new to me the years to
cause harm concept is not at all new
since
1993 nearly 30 years ago the
EPA made the formulas and software
freely available to find the the
calculated fixed radius from drinking
water wells with which in within which
new industrial facilities ought not to
be located so that's a two miles five
miles uh 10 miles a years out and so
that that is the concept we're talking
about and in that case depending on
other
considerations they chose you can choose
two five or 10 the scientists and people
involved in that decision and I have
here the website address of where this
material can be seen and you can look at
your leisure at this I I took the time
to do that and this is an absolutely
perfect uh website address rather than
merely talking about the theoretical
however I'm going to present two actual
examples of the years to cause harm
concept as it's documented in Coos
County where I
live the application pending at Dees for
an expansion of the existing landfill at
Mount carbury in Berlin success provides
data showing that contaminated
groundwater from that site would take 60
to 150 years to reach a
tributary of the Androgen River
this was just given in testimony for
that expansion at a public Hearing in
December so that is upto-date
information 60 to
150 years for groundwater to reach the
tributary of the Andrew Kagan
River the velocity was found to be about
50 feet per year there it is located in
appropriate soils and
bedrock in stark contrast the applicant
that has a pending but still incomplete
application to install a landfill in the
town of Dalton has already estimated the
groundwater Flows at that site at
9.5 feet per day or faster if de's
code um setback remains at only two 100
ft from a water body then the agency
might have only as little as 21 days to
notice and respond to a leak at a site
where groundwater flows this
quickly and remember monitoring isn't
required that frequently landfill
sighting is an important issue for this
state I and many of the public
testifying to gay agree with the premise
that we will need to continue to use
Solid Waste landfilling as a way to
dispose of some of the waste we generate
but we need to be realistic about how
many more landfills New Hampshire might
need and where we might need them
despite self-interested claims by at
least one publicly traded corporation
that there's a landfill capacity crisis
it's clear that New Hampshire has no
need for additional capacity until at
least the year
2034 a assuming the pending Mount carbur
landfill expansion moves for moves
forward there was no public opposition
at the December 2021 public Zoom hearing
I I understand that letters that might
have been coming come in are not yet
publicly available and If the turnkey
landfill in Rochester is allowed to
expand according to its original plan
not until
2045 or Beyond
so the answer to the question when will
we need more is 15 or 20 years away but
we are here today in part because there
is an active application pending in the
North Country although Dees has returned
a large part of it for a complete
rewrite for a new landfill that's
clearly located in a tract where
groundwater flows extremely rapidly and
where a major scenic River and a glacial
Lake are very
nearby there is no landfill crisis but
there is a crisis landfill which is why
I urge you to pass this bill this
session I think we all understand even
more than than we did a year ago that
for a variety of reasons mostly as a
Ways and Means Committee Member uh I
assume
budgetary Dees has allowed many years to
slip by without staying up to date on a
number of solid waste and waste related
issues although there may be a need to
tweak this proposed Bill's specific
language particularly in section
c and certainly to correct many
inaccuracies in the fiscal
note uh HB
14544 is ready for Prime Time designed
to help bring s up to date
now I have other handouts other things
to discuss if you'd like and I certainly
am happy to take questions particularly
once I got my glasses on and I can
see thank you representative excuse me
are there any questions for
representative
Tucker representative
MOA thank you very much um I had a
question for you what are the
problematic parts of C
you've identified it or you've noted I
think you're going to hear those uh
possibly from someone from uh DS
director whimet all right and uh he you
know somehow time ran away with me and I
didn't get as much done as I'd hoped to
in January and uh I I think we can
straighten those out I and I assume that
there could well be a subcommittee
formed from this committee but we are
eager
to work with the Department to work with
others to work with committee members
and get it so that this is a bill that
is a bipartisan bill that can be
embraced by this committee I think it's
very important I know you know here
in I know we all think our county is
unique but one of the things that is
unusual about Coos County is we only
have 10 represent
atives and when you
get a lot of people in Coos interested
and members interested right at the
moment we only have nine reps so it's to
get the enthusiasm to get the number of
people and on into Grafton County to
we're ready to go and we want to work to
get this build
ready representative
Aaron yes thank you and thank you for um
your testimony introducing this bill so
the EPA has this Source water protection
area page uh with that information and
um shows
how water this this the source water
protection areas and how they would be
delineated do you know if we have had
any kind of geologic survey done of the
entire State and our water ways uh which
would
already have given us some information
as
to what you're alluding to with this
bill in terms of
where sites could be done I was a
reporter for the coat County Democrat
for 25 years and I did Cover the
geologic survey when they finished it uh
all of New Hampshire has had
uh test fits but they're usually like 12
Ines or something like that so the deep
water they would not have done the
national forest was not done that
National Forest people did not believe
that there was going to be development
and therefore they really didn't need to
know specifically about the soils but
yes we do have but they probably it
would be a developer who would pay for
test fits on land that they were either
owned or were
considering I would think
uh we know that we have to do those kind
of test fits if we're putting in a
septic system at our own house and
they're perfectly
typical but yes uh probably your local
planning board has all the uh soil maps
and data on your town or city and you
know it was a big achievement that's why
they called the press it was a big
achievement when they finished New
Hampshire it must have been I know 15
years ago they did they did a something
up Mount Washington up at the state park
to draw the press and uh they did test
fits there follow
up so you're suggesting that this these
kinds of tests uh or surveys be
done based on site PCI spite site
specific
uh Notions of you know where where
something might be placed as opposed to
doing an entire geologic
survey which would take into
consideration maybe much deeper oh I
don't I'm not suggesting under this bill
that uh the whole state be surveyed but
I think that there are people who
believe that the state does because
there the state might well have a role
at some time in finding the best site in
the future but that is not part of this
bill this these tests uh are already
part of the application process so as I
think I said uh the developer will not
be surprised to find they're expected to
do this they already are doing it this
just moves it to the beginning of the
process because
you might find that what you had thought
would be a good site really isn't a good
site because of the rapidity or lack of
rapidity of the flow of water and so
that really is the big change is getting
it early on before Dees spends a lot of
time
and as I know because I live in southern
coas not only the de developer spends a
lot of time and de spends a lot of time
but the communities where there's a
possibility of
sighting uh landfill also spend a lot of
time thinking about whether it's their
planning board Conservation Commission
whatever or just neighborhood groups
it's something that's large from the
outside coming
in diverts attention and energy and
dollars
thank
you representative Murray thank you for
taking my question thank you um could
you talk a little bit more broadly about
the years to cause harm concept and is
that practice occurring here in in New
Hampshire where is where is the years to
cause harm um study metric being
implemented and I said I saw in your
testimony you said that it was not new
to you but it has existed for 20 to 30
years
I know I felt really kind of stupid so
I'm I'm what are there universities that
are using this or where is that
happening that
I see I'm trying to see which of these
things it's used typically on Industrial
sites in certain States and I wish I had
the language I'd hoped that Dr pinkle
could be here today but for a variety of
reasons he could not and U I'm I'm sure
uh I'm sorry I can't help you thank
you representative if you come across
said info going forward you could
certainly forward it to the committee if
you wanted you may be sure that by the
time I get home it will be on my iMac
the one thing about streaming
yes I just have one point of
clarification myself that I'd like to I
think I remember you saying this and I
want to make sure I understood it
because you've said it twice now so this
current
requirement is already in the process of
citing a landfill it's just not at the
front end it's further further down
right I I think I can find the exact
location in the
testimony uh yes the test involves
digging a few holes estimating the speed
at which the groundwater Flows at that
site and then sighting the landfill so
it would take at least five years for
any polluted groundwater to reach the
nurest lake river this test is already
part of all completed applications
submitted to Dees okay so HB 1454
creates no new burden for
developers it merely requires that the
test be done at the outset you
know uh Dr fle suggested to me that you
know if you were building a commercial
building in California you would
probably want to as a developer look
into whether you were right
on the conjunction of in plate tectonics
you know is it an earthquake zone that
you were building in and we're
suggesting that in landfills it's the
flow of the groundwater get that up
front just the way you would get up
front if you were thinking of buying a
parcel of land in Randolph and you were
planning to build yourself a log cabin
you would before you put your money down
probably you would get a perk test up
and find out whether you could have a
septic system there sure so having said
that I guess I'll I'll follow up with a
with a simple question that you had made
the statement that putting this in would
save the potential for a lot of money
later for clean up with but if it's
already required that they do this what
difference would it make when it's done
within the process about saving money
because if if if they are not allowed to
put this in at the secondary point I
mean I understand your points well Tak
but they're not putting it in for the
purpose there isn't anything that says
they only have the 200 ft so they have
the
information but it isn't in the rules
that that that's the criteria okay so
I'm not clear then so this information
is part of the process but it doesn't
have any weight within the process of
whether they issue a perent no I think
that director whims is here to answer
questions okay and he will be able very
specifically to be able to tell you what
exactly they do with that sure fair
enough but there is nothing like five
years now it's wonderful that I live not
that far from Mount carbury and it is a
great and I've toured that landfill
twice uh it is a big operation it's
cited wear this
clay and you know the people who worked
at the Mill many of whom you know
in had jobs that I knew they were in the
sort of semi management middle
management they were responsible for
finding a place to put Industrial Waste
we know that you can't have
manufacturing without having a place to
take Industrial Waste and it's very
important that it not flow sure into the
rivers understood well thank you I
appreciate it I'll certainly forward
that question to director whims when he
comes any other questions for
representative
Tucker all right seeing n so could it be
that I could be called back to the
microphone if something comes up that
needs and other
answers I we can let's let's see how we
do in the process I do have a schedule I
have to keep so I'm just a little
concerned if I give a second bite at the
I took quite a lot of time that's okay I
thank you for your well deserved we'll
see if time will allow but thank
you okay uh representative Perez is next
and asking for three three minutes to
speak good afternoon representative you
may start when you're ready good
afternoon thank you uh Mr chair for
letting me speak uh thank you members of
the committee for listening to my
testimony and members of the public for
listen to My Testimony as well my name
is Maria Perez I'm a state
representative for district 23 in
Milford I'm here to speak in support of
this bill one of the reason that I'm
supporting this bill is because I live
in a town that we have two super size um
with contamination and not just the
water but the soil in Mur and it is
critical it is critical for us to
protect the water especially the
drinking water myself um I'm one of
those people who has very low immune
system I have chronic lme disease and I
have other chronic illness that um
anything that is like in the soil or the
air of water is um not helping my immune
system so I believe this is critical it
is critical for us to protect the water
before we has to um buy the water for
another town in or city of New Hampshire
because in milfer we have to pay for uh
water that comes for penish water in
Nashville um and the reason being is
because um we have like I say we have
this two super siiz and Milford that
since um 1948 until 1991 they
contaminated water and soil in our town
so that's one of the reason that I'm
super supported this bill because I
believe it's time for us to protect the
water before other town of city that has
to buy water from penal water probably
different company but I I believe um
it's critical for us to protect the
water and
soil
thank you representative will you take
any questions yes are there any
questions for representative
Perez seeing none we thank you for your
testimony next we have up U Muriel
robinet Robin not quite sure on the
pronunciation
there Mel I'm not clear on who you're
representing so if you could please tell
us
sorry I couldn't quite read the hand
ready turn yes I'd be happy to tell you
thank you um thank you very much for
allowing me to speak in support of this
house built um I am representing the
North Country ABC and New Hampshire land
law I've been a lifelong resident of
this state and I'm a practicing
hydrogeologist for the record my name is
muel
robinet the reason I'm speaking here is
because I'm very passionate about New
Hampshire I'm very passionate about our
out ofd doors and I know that it's
extremely important that the work that
Dees does in trying to do the very best
for the State of New Hampshire and
sometimes it helps to give them a little
stronger tools to be able to do their
job so what we're talking about here in
this house bill is about an existing
setback and that's as the crow flies 200
feet
and it applies when they're going to
site a waste disposal facility that is
going to be in existence for the better
part of hundred years and that waste
disposal facility has the potential to
contaminate rivers and lakes for that
100 years including our wonderful P
contamination that we all hear way too
much about so this is a really important
issue and it's a huge criteria and
concern that Dees needs to get right we
want them to get it
right now as you drive around the state
of New Hampshire it all doesn't look the
same you go whether it's from the Sea
Coast up through the valleys to our
great Northwoods and into the mountains
what you see is a variable landscape
well it's like that underground also and
hydrog ologists have spent their Decades
of practice in understanding what that
underground system looks like and how it
reacts there are specialists at Dees
that do the same thing and they're very
capable of evaluating the data that is
necessary so in the case of of citing a
landfill we're concerned
about not
having it be any sort of a located in an
area that can create a problem and
you've heard the term five years well
why five years rather than having a 200
foot setback one size fits all as the
crow flies what this bill is proposing
is using a groundwater flow because
groundwater is that Vector that can
carry contaminants into rivers and lakes
and so why five years why why not 10
years why not one year and it comes down
to the fact that we are all humans and
we have to react to what we find out and
when a landfill is in existence and in
operation there's a monitoring schedule
and when contamination is discovered
there has to be a a a response to that
contamination that's flowing in the
groundwater towards lakes and Rivers you
can't do that overnight that's not a
one-week response it takes generally
years to be able to respond any of you
who have lived in a town where there's a
superf fund site you know that it can
take the the EPA 10 years or more to
come up with a remedy to try to to
address the
contamination and you don't have 10
years here in New Hampshire particularly
if groundwater flow is rapid and that's
the whole point of this bill is to have
a site
specific
setback and the evaluation of
groundwater flow is something that's
done as part of most sites in New
Hampshire whether it's water resources
or sites that have
contamination there are basic studies
it's a science that's been known for 150
years and they drill Wells and they do
hydraulic tests and they come up with
groundwater flow rates it's a well-known
science and Dees reviews those kind of
calculations on a regular basis so this
bill is proposing that if you have
groundwater flow that can reach a river
or a lake in five years or less that's
not an appropriate place to site a
landfill because over a 100 Years of of
uh the life of the landfill can
contaminants can move into those lakes
and rivers and what's the purpose of the
setback is to protect lakes and rivers
and so why allow the sighting of a
landfill that has two short a
setback 200 feet one size fits all
doesn't answer that if you were driving
through OIP recently you see all those
lovely sand and gravel uh resources that
are there groundwater flow in that area
can be you know six eight 10 feet per
day if you try to sight a landfill in
the area of those oap resources you
might have to have a thousand foot
setback in order to be protective of the
rivers and lakes if you have a place on
oy Lake you'd appreciate
that so it's just a question of having a
setback that is appropriate and
protective for our lakes and rivers I
urge you to support this Bill thank
you thank you will you take any
questions yes I will take questions all
right are there any any questions from
Miss
rette representative
amola hi thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious if you have a
site that uh has leakage and it
saturates for five miles right you have
to five miles for that once you create
that line of saturation is it a
continuous flow or is does it just
constantly EB and flow I'm not sure I
understand the five miles well I'm sorry
five years I'm so sorry five years I had
five stuck in my head um so if you've
created a site and you have five years
to where it reaches that water
body does that continue does that
establish the line of saturation at that
point
or does it just e and flow with what's
happening with
groundwater groundwater in general is in
a saturated condition in the in the
subsurface and so this is assuming that
you've got saturated soil or fractured
rock or in in underneath this landfill
and once the contamination is detected
in the monitoring Wells that's your
fiveyear window before it gets to the
river the once
contamination is there it it usually
doesn't go away by itself except over a
long period of time when it can slowly
biodegrade because you're never taking
away the
source or you're going to have to
install a remedy to cut off the
contamination so it doesn't go into the
lake or river that's the whole point of
the five years you have a fiveyear
warning kind of the canary in the coal
mine once you find the contamination in
a monitoring well well then you B
basically got hopefully more than 5
years before it actually hits the
surface water body so you have time to
put in do something fix it okay thank
you I just wondered if it was you know
dependent obviously drought it things
like that it's a constantly moving
Target or if it's always assuming a
saturation it's a pretty continuous
process when you have your source as a
Continuum thank
you representative vix yes thank you for
taking my question what sorts of if uh
contamination is discovered in one of
the test Wells what sorts of remedies
would be available to deal with it I
apologize I'm having a hard time
understanding what you're saying okay
sorry uh if contamination is found in a
well one of the test Wells what sorts of
remedies would be available to deal with
that well this would be obviously for an
operating landfill if it has
contamination that's outside the test
Wells and so the concept would be how do
you either cut it off do some sort of a
cut off wall or treatment wall in place
so that as the groundwater continually
flows through it can be treated before
it hits the surface water body the the
River or the lake or the worst case is
some sort of a hydraulic containment
where you do pump and treat and you
actually pump the water out and that
creates a a hydraulic barrier from it
continue to move
but what we're really trying to focus
here is not to get to that situation so
instead you would only site landfills
where you have a much
longer time frame to be able to come up
with a a treatment if you need to or
possibly it could create contamination
that you don't end up having to pull
back because you do have so much time
before it would actually Reach the the
lake or river thank you
any further
questions seeing none we thank you for
your testimony thank you I have written
copies here if you would like certainly
please you can give them to Poma here
over on the
end okay next we'll uh call up Tim White
from sandbo
head
go ahead and whenever you're ready thank
you good afternoon chairman Pearl and
members of the committee my name is Tim
White and I'm a Project Director at
sanor head and Associates an engineering
and geosciences firm headquartered here
in conquer I'm one of the
hydrogeologists at samor head
responsible for managing the groundwater
monitoring programs at several of the
state's public and private landfills and
I've worked in the field of hydrogeology
for over 20
years in my opinion the Bill's
Provisions do not represent a novel or
comprehensive groundwater management
strategy and would create an consistent
regulatory landscape briefly here today
I want to summarize my written comments
by touching on two points regarding
technical shortcomings in the bill the
first is the requirement to immediately
shut down a landfill if a priority
pollutant is detected at any
concentration above
Baseline in my written comments I
provide a hypothetical but plausible
scenario where a landfill could be shut
down for weeks to months due to a very
low level detection of a pollutant even
below drinking water water and surface
water standards and even if the source
is not the landfill
itself simply put a potential source of
contamination cannot be conclusively
identified from a single exceedence in a
groundwater
sample my second concern is the
inconsistencies in permitting that would
arise between new landfills and
expansion at existing
sites for example under the Bill's
Provisions it is possible that new and
expanded landfills could have the same
line ER systems leech and gas collection
systems and waste types and capacities
yet they would be regulated much
differently I'm not aware of another
industry in the state of New Hampshire
that has similar limitations placed on
sighting and operating facilities to
have differing levels of environmental
permitting and regulation makes no
regulatory or technical sense for
example the requirement for a minimum
5year groundwater travel time to a
fourth order stream or lake is an
arbitrary benchmark it would not be
applicable only to new landfills not to
expansions hp1 1454 does not provide an
explanation for this requirement and
there is no basis for it under nhdes
regulations shouldn't all of New
Hampshire's Water Resources be protected
under a uniform
approach in closing hp1 1454 should be
struck down as written because of the
technical infeasibility of implementing
its standards in conjunction with
standard industry practice and
duplication of current nhdes regulatory
requirements thank you for the
opportunity to appear before the
committee today and I welcome questions
you may
have all right any uh questions from Mr
White yes representative C yes thank you
for taking my questions Mr White are are
you saying that there is no industry
where new regulations would apply to new
facilities where they could not where
old facilities would not
be those regulations would not be
applicable to Old facilities uh thank
you representative I'm not to clarify
I'm not aware of a uh an industry where
such a stark difference is uh is
specified at the permitting and sighting
stage between indust industrial
sites any other questions from Mr
White
all right thank you sir thank
you all right next we will uh call on
Tom Tower from North Country Alliance
for balance
change
chairman Pearl members of the House
environment and agriculture committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today and I can promise you I will not
attempt to discuss science regarding
this bill uh for the record my name is
Tom Tower I'm a resident of Whitefield
and speaking here today on uh behalf of
North Country Alliance for balance
change um in support of house bill
1454 so last year there was an enormous
amount of support from people across the
state in favor of what was then House
Bill
177 which worked to prevent the sighting
of a landfill within two miles of uh and
create a buffer around a state park and
as you
recall House Bill
177 hotly debated eventually passed in
the
house uh but ultimately failed in in the
Senate so although it ultimately was
unsuccessful the momentum that that
legislation proposed legislation had
across the state um wasn't necessarily
unprecedented but became a bit of a
catalyst for what you are seeing today
which is an an enormous amount of
proposed Bill some 30 plus in relation
to environment water pasas certainly
Solid Waste one such Bill House Bill
1450 for which seeks to create
science-based setbacks for new landfills
from any perennial river lake or Coastal
water the drafters of 1454 listened
carefully to the concerns that this
committee and the senate had in regards
to 177 and worked to develop a smart and
workable piece of legislation we thank
the members of this committee for
bringing to the attention of the people
who proposed the legislation that there
were some flaws in that as it relates to
targeting specific projects uh the fact
that uh there may be a level of
unconstitutionality the the the fact
that it was limited in its scope this
particular Bill protects all New
Hampshire lakes and rivers this is about
the state it's not about the North
Country smart project sighting is not
just a North Country issue this
legislation will protect all valuable
State resources from our Coastline to
the Maramar River Lake Waki Lake snipe
and every town in between as we've seen
with Posas this is not about telling
people or developers what they can and
can't do it's about making
sure what they do doesn't carry lifelong
detrimental effects to our communities
and our state thank you and I would be
happy to take
questions all right thank you Mr Tower
is there any uh any questions for Mr
tower all right seeing none thank you
sir thank you to the committee and I do
have copies of my testimony
perfect next up we'll call Fred Anderson
from
Whitefield life gets
complicated none of that's going into
the toilet I
trust you had to be here
earlier uh thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you to
members of the committee my name is Fred
Anderson and I live in Whitefield uh
this is the third time I've appeared
before this Committee in the last three
years the first one was on the House
Bill 1319 which you voted ought to pass
it was sent on to the Senate and
unfortunately it became a victim of
covid in that year in which much good
legislation just didn't get passed last
year I sat before you in the virtual
meeting urging you to support House Bill
177 in that conversation a number of you
mentioned that the primary reasons you
had trouble with that bill were
three the first one was the bill was
about state parks and again and again
you ask me why is this about Parks
instead of water why is this about land
instead of this precious resource of
water second you said the setback was
arbitrary that circle around state parks
was an arbitrary number the third was
The Proposal lacked any kind of credible
scientific backup so House Bill 1454 has
been designed to address three of those
very valuable critiques we listen to you
and we went back to the drawing board
and we have constructed this bill in
hopes that you will pass it it's about
protecting the major sources of drinking
water in the state from contamination of
lee8 peos other carogin and from leaking
landfills that will poison lakes and
rivers that feed private Wells like mine
right on Forest Lake as well as
Municipal aquires fed by like the amusic
river it doesn't arbitr doesn't operate
with an arbitrary setback as is the case
by the way right now with the 200 foot
that the dees messed work with by the
way they don't have an option on that
one we're talking about giving Dees some
criteria that enables them to make
better decisions their hands are tied in
terms of what they're told their their
criteria has to be so this would be a
change in de's
criteria that 200 foot is not only
arbitrary but it's
dangerous hp1
1454 corrects that with the varable
verifiable
hydrology measuring the speed of
groundwater at multiple surfaces to
determine the speed of water flow within
the soils of the anticipated site the
highest speed of those flows whether
surface or deep comes the measurement
that gets multiplied by the five years
that Dees has set as the time that is
required to address stop
remediate a leak or a plume I don't
think this bill says shut down a
landfill until it's remediated that's
what I was hearing suggested a moment
ago if the site is found to be at least
5 Years From the lake or river it is
deemed suitable as an accident
can be addressed without compromising
the water the permitting application
could move forward for further input and
evaluation but if not is simply not an
acceptable site this means among other
things it will lighten the workload of
Dees staff a permit comes in and if it's
suitable then it's worth Dees spending
time looking at it but if it's not it
can be shut down right up front and D
Dees doesn't have to wa we staff time or
any other time in terms of deciding
whether or not this is a viable site
further it gives Dees an actual number
to work with in terms of their
evaluation of whether not the site is
appropriate the bill is anything but
anti- landfill the landfills are to be
the place of Last Resort for waste that
cannot be otherwise reused repurposed
recycled or composted
it is abundantly clear that we need them
but we need them safely designed we need
them appropriately cited and responsibly
manag so this bill is about ensuring
that new landfills and not this is about
new landfills not existing applications
not Carberry is not going to be covered
by this turn key is not going to be
covered by this by the way we also know
those are in soils that are not terribly
porous so we don't need to worry about
it this is about new landfills and where
new landfills go and are they being
appropriately cited in New Hampshire for
the sake of preserving what is
increasingly one of this state's most
precious resources are drinking water I
urge you to vote Yes ought to pass on
House Bill 15
1454 and I thank you for your time and
your attention and your
service thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr
Anderson didn't ask him he takes some
but I knew from previous experience that
he
[Laughter]
would seeing none I think we're going to
let you off this time thank
you so the final card that I have is uh
director
whims representative M you could send
the blue sheet
up
if there is anyone else that wishes to
speak if you want to fill out a card and
send it this way it' be a good time to
do
so good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Mike whims I serve as director of the
waste management division for New
Hampshire
Dees and uh appreciate the opportunity
to testify in house 1454
uh again to be clear department is not
taking a position on this bill upon
review we did Identify some concerns um
that we wanted to share with the
committee and first off
um uh the this been discussion of the
five-year groundwater travel time and uh
DS only just wants to point out that
given the complexity of the geology and
the um hydrogeology and the way that
aquifers uh are
exist in New Hampshire they're very
heterogeneous they're complex and trying
to um identify a specific fiveyear
travel time in a given portion of an oer
is not always an easy thing we just want
to point out that that may be more
complex than a read of the bill would
would give the reader you know to would
have a reader expect um we also note
that to the extent that um the work that
would the field studies that would need
to be done right now it is the case that
they look at um that under the sighting
criteria and under the requirements for
citing a new landfill there are some
studies of soils immediately in the
footprint of the landfill but that only
tells you one thing it only tells you
what the soils beneath the landfill are
comprised of and how they move or don't
move water very well um what it doesn't
tell you is what is between that
landfill site and the surface water that
this bill is looking to protect and so
to do the field studies you would need
to really get a reasonably accurate view
of travel time depending on the site you
may you may well need to do work off of
the site um between the landfill site
and the surface water and we note that
while that could be difficult because if
it it's probably very well could be on
land that is not owned by a landfill
applicant and therefore there would be
potentially some access issues so we
just wanted to point that out to the
committee um the second concern is uh
that the uh the monitoring Well Network
that would be required what the bill
requires is that so you determine what
is a 5-year travel distance for for
groundwater from the landfill site and
if you meet those criteria and the
landfill is theoretically then
permittable at least with respect to
that that fiveyear travel time distance
um the bill would require the applicant
to then put a monitoring Well Network in
the area that is 5 miles travel you know
groundwater travel time distance from
the surface water and it's not clear to
us how that how doing that would provide
any more protectiveness than what the
current our monitoring requirements are
so if you think about it just
conceptually if you have a landfill here
and a surface water there and let's say
the average the the five fiveyear travel
time distan is here you'd be required to
put a monitor Well Network here and
monitor that right now under current
conditions there's a requirement to put
a a network of monitoring Wells immedi
adjacent to the landfill and the
intention of that is to provide for the
earliest possible detection of releases
from the landfill and an opportunity to
monitor that monitor that and then take
appropriate steps if you detect a leak
um so what's just to give you an idea
what happens right now if we permit a
landfill or a landfill expansion there's
an expectation that in order to site
that there you need to be able to
provide a monitoring Well Network that's
capable of U monitoring groundwater that
could be impacted by the landfill and
then that that Network would be
protective of Downstream drinking water
sources so that Network in all cases
that our landfills in the state is
generally pretty much immediately
adjacent to and I mean within a within
100 feet or so of of the landfill
footprint and then um that's monitored
under the provisions of a groundwater
release detection permit which is a
permit it's an enforcable permit that
requires uh regular monitoring sampling
of those Wells for a host of
parameters and that's the routine that
just goes on for the throughout the life
and the post closure care life of a
landfill if during that time so you
establish background concentrations of a
variety of geochemical parameters and
contaminants if during that time you
identify any exceedence of the
background So you you're you're
monitoring for contaminants you're
monitoring for you know things that are
already in the groundwater like iron and
manganese and things like that if you
see a significant increase over the
background for any one of those
contaminants that triggers what's called
assessment monitoring and assessment
monitoring as opposed to detection
monitoring is um more intensive for a
larger host larger panel of contaminants
and the purpose of that is to determine
essentially um you to confirm that
there's there's actually something going
on and then there's a requirement to
submit a plan for investigating and
remediating whatever may be causing that
so we believe believe that that system
um is
capable really having the wells
immediately adjacent to the landfill
that's going to give you your earliest
detection and your earliest opportunity
to identify whether there's really a
release from the landfill or whether
it's some other reason and there are
cases where that happens and then if it
is to address it in the event that that
can't be addressed there are already
Provisions in our rules that require
that the that the landfill operator
begin if they if they can't fix the
problem they have to begin um basically
submit a schedule for closure of the
facility so that is the basically the
current regime so it's unclear to us how
this monitoring Well Network that
presumably would be further ailed from
the landfill and would be need to be
require monitored and also I would note
may also be on private property so there
could be access issues it's not clear to
us how that would provide enhanced
protection over what exists right now
and then the third concern that we have
is that the bill requires
if uh in that monitoring Well Network
that's at the fiveyear travel time
distance from the surface water body if
uh you identify an exceedance as we read
the bill it requires the landfill to
cease operations until the the Plumas is
is you know evaluated and remediated and
we have some concerns about that because
particularly in the case where you have
a monitoring Well Network that's further
a field from the landfill it's entirely
possible that anything you would see for
an exceedence of the background
condition could come from something
other than the landfill so it's not
really a fair provision in that sense um
but even if it is from the landfill the
current system and we're very familiar
with it because we implement it um gives
an opportunity of the landfill operator
to identify the problem figure out
whether it's really a release from the
landfill and then fix it um if you just
assume as soon as you get a detection
above standards that you haven't even
really confirmed yet you're going to
close the landfill down we believe that
could needlessly create Some solid waste
capacity crisis or you know challenges
or shortages and really be it's an
unfair provision so that's um that's our
concerns and I'm happy to to field any
questions thank you director so I'll
start myself I guess the I'll ask you
the similar question to what I had asked
representative Tucker that you know the
assertion is she made that this was part
of the current process that
uh that's there now it doesn't sound
like it exactly is it sounds like
there's something similar from what
you're describing is is yeah well I
believe what um and again I certainly
would never never attempt to speak for
representative Tucker but I think what
she may have been referring to is under
the rules uh the solid waste rules uh
the citing criteria for a solid waste
landfill there are a number of
Provisions that need to be met and one
of them is that you need to do enough
um study of your actual site to get a
reasonable um understanding of the
groundwater regime of the groundwater
flow regime and that includes getting
some data about how the soils behave and
how they move how fast they move
groundwater but on the heels of getting
that the purpose for that under the
rules is really really so you can just
describe the hydrogeologic setting it
doesn't then translate to a travel time
distance or anything like that so it
seems from my understanding of this is
that this bill is requiring work to be
done that's offsite of where the actual
proposed landfill is am I reading that
correctly depending on the particular
site and the and the nature of the
aquifer I do believe it could require
field testing that would go off of the
landfill site yes one final question
that came from your
testimony So currently if there is a
detection in one of the monitoring Wells
I guess two-part question what's the
current uh frequency of monitoring of
those detection Wells and then if there
is something that uh you know that comes
up that needs to you figure needs to
have some remediation done or or further
testing that what happens then is that
is that frequency stepped up it can
differ depending on the circumstances
but at a minimum generally our
groundwater release detection permits
would require a minimum of tri-annual
monitoring so every four months and then
if you do identify it's really very
specific if you identify a uh an
exceedence of particular contaminant
over Baseline in in any one well then
basically a enhanced monitoring uh net
of plan would be developed to address
that specific situation which could
include more frequent monitoring and
often does might that include
installation of new test Wells further
out to try and understand how quickly
that's moving yes it could thank you any
other questions for director whimet
representative Bixby yes thank you for
taking my question um
so
uh representative Tucker mentioned that
in section c uh there were issues that
she recognized needed to be fixed and it
seems like uh this the location of the
modering wells might be part might be
part of that uh so would you see uh if
if the bill uh worked with the existing
uh structure or me mechanism of having
monitoring Wells right around the
landfill uh would you see that as a
partial fix of the problems that you
noted in section
c I think that would be an improvement I
and I should note that I did speak at
some length with Dr Adam finle and with
representative Tucker in advance of this
hearing to discuss these concerns that
I'm describing for you today follow
up uh so uh do the is that monitoring
regime currently in rules or is it in
statute uh it I think its basis is in
statute but the details of it are are
contained in the rules so it would be a
fairly straightforward to reference
where it exists now as a way of
correcting section
c um if I understand your question I'm
not sure I do understand your question
okay so so so there there is existing
language that sets up those that that
monitoring Sy monitoring system
absolutely and if we were to adopt that
as part of an amendment to section c
then that that could get us in the
direction of of U making the bill better
I'm not sure that it would be necessary
to adopt it in a new bill because it
already exists in Rule and has been
determined by the legislature to be in
that you know pass the muster with the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules I'm not sure why it
would need to be included in the in the
law I guess if you're asking if the if
the bill were amended
to um more closely align with that
existing system yes yeah I think that
would be an improvement sure thank
you any other questions from the
director all right so we'll start with
representative Kaplan yes thank you for
taking my question um in your experience
under the current regime have there ever
been any situations or any instances of
leaks from landfill to
groundwater we have had situations in
groundwater monitoring um like I just
described where we do see a contaminant
that goes above Baseline and then we
have indeed in a number of cases
required that landfill operator to go
into the assessment monitoring phase and
develop a remedial action plan and uh in
the cases that I'm familiar with um it
has in some cases been a release of
leech eight not from the landfill itself
but a release that occurred during leech
eight handling because of course le8 is
collected by Design at landfills pumped
off to trucks and typically transported
to wastewater treatment plants for for
disposal and in some cases the
infrastructure used to collect the leech
a or the actual transfer process to a
truck has resulted in a release and so
that is certainly capable of causing a
detection in one of those monitoring
Wells so so that has happened um in
other cases uh um I'm trying to think of
other cases we've had uh but more direct
to answer your question we're not from
we're not aware of a landfill leachate
release that has impacted one of these
monitoring LS it typically been
something that happened from outside the
landfill but closest thing was at one
facility we had Landfield lee8 that did
get to the soil and impacted a well but
it wasn't because of a liner failure it
was because of a construction failure a
temporary construction failure during
the construction of an inter cap and uh
as a result of the process the process
worked in that case the facility um went
into assessment monitoring confirmed it
uh started uh exploring and
investigating and identified the
deficiency in the interim cap and went
in and repaired it and then that well
returned to meet
standards further questions
representative
VY I'm sorry representative Perez you
testified on on the bill itself so
you're not allowed to ask questions of
another person
testifying it's okay if you have a
question maybe you want to slip to
another member they could ask it for you
perhaps representative
Aaron thank you Mr chair thank you so
much for your testimony today so my
question is in this
bill it requires that
um that the
uh
there's there's a fiveyear migrating
offsite
limitation in other words it would have
to take five years before any kind of
contaminant reaches uh a body of water
and I'm wondering um could there ever be
any kind of change Hydro geologically to
the the ground between the landfill and
a body of water that would happen
to change that fiveyear window I mean
barring an earthquake or something like
that well it's possible I guess a
dramatic example would be like a river
evulsion like we had in the sunro river
a number of years ago during a flood
event where River actually changes the
location of its channel so theoretically
if you're protecting a river and there
were that particular River evoled and
and moved its Channel closer to the
landfill then you could you could have a
shorter travel time or likewise if it
evolves in the other direction you could
uh you could have a longer
distance okay thank
you any other
questions representative Tucker I see
you're raising your
hand well right now representative whims
is testify excuse me director whims is
testifying
sure any other questions for the
director all right seeing none we thank
you sir for
testimony actually we do have another
card here I'm sorry we got one that came
in um John Tut Hill from aworth has
requested no particular time to speak so
how how long do you intend to speak sir
briefly briefly all right I'll take
that for the record my name is John Tut
Hill and I'm from aor New Hampshire
Sullivan County I did not intend to uh
speak or testify on this bill although I
do support the bill uh
strongly uh I am not taking a position
on the director's testimony however I do
have some
concerns uh that the department or the
division I should say I don't think is
grasping the uh one very important
aspect of this bill and that is we're
talking about um setting a standard as
opposed to a 200 foot standard rules uh
which deals with the velocity of
groundwater flow as you heard in earlier
testimony so a lot of what was discussed
uh in the divisions testimony has to do
with what happens once the site has has
been permitted built and is operating
and I certainly know of sites Beth uh
excuse me uh Newport New Hampshire for
example had Nash landfill I think the
last new landfill to be permitted in the
state in the
1980s there were breaches there there
was contamin there and it was closed
early um groundwater flow is something
you want to look at before you have
permanent a facility built it and began
operating it when you have problems
after operations have begun it gets
incredibly expensive sites for example
in Hanover New
Hampshire um you know you can do
extensive mapping of of Bedrock as
they're doing at kle landfill down on
the Sea Coast uh in Handover they had to
do that if that had been done beforehand
you would have known that that was not
an appropriate site to be placing uh
relatively hazardous materials this is
another issue in New Hampshire landfills
have gotten very very large very
expensive highly engineered if you're
going to be making that kind of
investment let's make that investment in
an appropriate location and let's find
out what is really going on uh with with
groundwater with bedrock uh before um
you even decide to begin the permitting
process that's what this bill is about
uh the
director's uh information about what
happens with monitoring systems is very
important and it was good to hear that
but I think we need to have further
discussions with Dees about the intent
of this particular bill so I I urge that
conversation take place uh and that we
have this is probably not the best form
for it but that we get to a point where
we all understand what we're trying to
achieve uh with House Bill 1454
thank you thank you for your testimony
any questions yes representative Bixby
so uh if I could just um see if I can uh
sum up uh part of the point here is that
by setting a standard that would be
assessed very early in the sighting
process what you're doing is saving a
business the time and money that it
might take so that they wouldn't invest
in a place where they shouldn't be and
at the same time saving Dees the time
and money of trying to permit something
that eventually would not be
appropriately set
there yes I would agree with that
although Dees under the current rules
would be very likely uh obliged to issue
that permit as long as all of the the
current standards were met and I think
this is part of the problem is that in
rules that 200 foot setback with no
consideration given to groundwater
flow uh simply is not protected and that
should be I think the primary criteria
for sighting is the level of
Environmental Protection that can be
provided by the that particular geology
and hydrogeology New England is a tough
place to site disposal facilities
because we there's a lot that is unknown
about about Bedrock for example what's
happening at kle is incredibly expensive
we're 20 30 years in I was involved with
that back in the 80s we knew then that
we were in trouble it's already had a
super fund clean up if we had you know
the kinds of standards that would have
prevented that operation from ever
opening you know millions and millions
and millions of dollars would have been
saved and frankly a threat to Public
Health would have been avoided so I I
urge you to take a
precautionary approach to this this
issue and I think that New Hampshire
really does need to bring their their
their sighting standards up into the
Modern Age thank you thank you any
further questions from Mr
Tu okay seeing none we thank you for
your testimony thank you representative
Tucker I have about five minutes that I
will sort of give you an extra bite of
the Apple here if you've got a closing
statement you'd like to
make I forgotten until the testimony of
the Reverend
uh Mr Anderson
that this is our third time around
because Co interrupted us the first time
and I wasn't as involved in that and uh
I'd sort of forgotten that so I do know
that we're all still wildly impacted by
Co and there's a tendency to want to
sort of get everything done figure out
whether we're going to meet in rep's
hall or not and get on with it but in
this
case I do pledge myself and the team of
people that has assembled to take on
this issue I think we're very close to
coming up with something that can be
passed there are some problems I think
you heard about them
today
please give us the time with a sub
committee if that's what it takes or the
whole
committee I know we have the cooperation
of DS and director
whims and there are others who will
weigh in the way our
last uh person who testified did and we
can come up with something that's going
to protect New Hampshire the way it
should where we're in this Century with
this uh this is a big problem and having
toured Mount carbur the size of today's
land that's extremely well-run and turns
out well
cited uh they're just absolutely
enormous if you've not ever gone to a
Modern Landfill and toured it take a
vacation day and do it it is I've also
been of course the one in Bethlehem so I
have Ted two modern
landfills and they are big and they're
talking about many many years that they
are on the landscape so I ask you to
indulge us and yourselves with giving a
little time for this to be worked out so
that we have something that you can
Embrace and endorse thank you very much
representative Tucker I have one
question I'd like to ask you before you
would me depart
you you have a have presented a bill
with a tremendous amount of information
and some some very uh viable ideas in my
opinion but I think we have as a
committee we're going to have some work
that we're going to need to do with them
to understand and digest you know some
of the contrary points that were made
would you be amendable if we decided as
a committee to include this as part of
our study committee looking at site
landfill sighting criteria because I
think some of what you've got is exactly
what we were thinking of looking at you
know I'm afraid we really don't have the
time I really think we need it this year
there is a pending application that does
tie de's hands a little bit but it is
not the application is not now
complete and really this if we could
work
through this year I think it could be
done I personally think a well-meaning
group of people who respect one another
could get this in order I take some
blame myself uh director whimet did give
me the alert and I didn't move quickly
enough I was a little surprised to find
ourselves you know meeting in January
and I had a second bill I was Prime
sponsor of so part of the problem is
mine uh but I think if you could find
two or three people who are willing to
spend some time between Zoom we all know
how to use these tools so that we don't
have to spend time traveling and having
lunch and all that stuff uh I think we
could get it done and I really would
much prefer that to being part of a
long-term study we know this study
doesn't really happen till next fall
and time goes by and who knows what
variant is going to come down on covid I
had forgotten until I heard the test
testimony of the Reverend Mr Anderson
that we had spent time before and then
it co interrupted that we had something
that was going forward so I think that
in the interest of defeating cids we
should take this on and get this done
now thank you representative thank you
okay I've got the blue sheet here hold
on we have one more question question
chair actually is this an early bill or
a regular bill you know something I have
to look I don't I don't know off the top
of my head if it is or
not I have a sheet here someplace that
tells
me okay so it's not an Oly
Bill okay uh the blue sheet is here we
have 12 people signing in six yay six
Nay with that I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1454 and we will
open house bill 1652 in about 3 three
minutes
I signed
up
e
is rep Ean here I have a card oh there
is back there
okay all right uh we're going to open up
the public hearing on house bills 1652
FN relative to the recycling of Beverage
containers and I will call on rep Ean to
introduce the
bill
it's hard to read and have a mask
because they fog up so thank you Mr
chair thank you uh esteem colleagues in
the house and on this committee I
appreciate you making time to hear from
me regarding House Bill
um I'll try to be brief but I do want to
give you my sincere
thoughts Hospital
1652 is an important bill for protecting
our economy our environment safeguarding
our tourism industry and improving the
lives of our constituents by overall
keeping the costs of bottled and canned
drinks
down you might question why that is tied
to a bottle bill that asks for or 10
cents to be added to a Redemption fee
but I will explain so we all know that R
recycling reduces solid waste and
reduces the need for landfill space and
I think you've heard a lot about that
today and that's an important topic to
tie into this issue but it does so much
more Economic Development comes from
redemption centers where town transfer
stations can gain
revenue transfer station can reduce
tipping fees saving
towns costs and reducing
taxpayers the liability of those costs
redemption centers can drive traffic
into new areas that would come from
Redemption of bottles and
cans and economic development also
happens because those businesses will
appeal to that do have an add redention
centers to their existing businesses
will appeal to conscious consumers folks
will want to come to that business to
redeem their bottles and cans because
they feel that that company is doing
well by doing good on behalf of
society now the industry will say that
it is costly but the industry is now
also saying that their costs are going
up because of globalization and raw
material prices are going up so in
creating more bottles and
cans around the world without recycling
them the cost of products to Consumers
to New Hampshire residents will go up
that price will keep going up because
the cost of raw materials are going up
as opposed to a
momentarily and redeemable
fee for Redemption on bottles and
cans will be a one-time cost for
consumers that they can actually get
back so we can either look at the
long-term costs to consumers or we can
look at a one-time redeemable
cost to
Consumers another thing that is
important to understand is
that when we pay higher costs we're not
protecting the
environment right why would we not want
to pay a fraction of a
cost that adds to a bottle or can that
you can get redeemed that you can get
that money back and you're protecting
the environment at the same time so
without Redemption we have cost of
products going up
we're hurting the
environment with Redemption RIS with
cycling product cost going up
momentarily getting it redeemed
protecting the
environment I think another important
thing to remember is that we're
safeguarding
tourism it's the number two industry in
the state of New Hampshire roughly $6
billion in Revenue comes into the state
of New Hampshire from tourism take a
moment to drive through a neighborhood
that has up state park that has a
playground that has on ramps to highways
you will notice bottles and cans being
tossed
aside would you drive down the street
and throw nickels and dimes out your
window I doubt you'd do that I doubt
you'd take a dollar bill crumple it up
and throw it out your
window but people are throwing 10
bottles and cans outside their window
because they don't care we need to give
them a reason to care a financial
incentive to
care recycling helps keep costs of the
product from going up drastically
instead of
momentarily so understanding that a dime
to a customer that can be
redeemed is a simple
fee for a moment but in the long term
has a tremendous Financial positive
impact on our
environment states around us are
currently all using a bottle Bell
Connecticut Maine Massachusetts New York
Vermont we need to join the other New
England states that have Canon bottle
redemption bills if those states can
manage to put together an infrastructure
to redeem beverage containers I could
see no reason why New Hampshire can't do
it in fact I think New Hampshire can do
it better we're very good at looking at
best practices and worst practices
taking what exists from that from that
information and creating good laws that
support and improve the lives of New
Hampshire
residents I think we should be in a race
with other New England states about
bragging rights of which states can have
the highest
recycling a 10% 10 cent per container
fee that people can recoup when they
return their containers would be a great
incentive to help keep New Hampshire
beautiful not
littered the incentive is needed because
despite what we think many containers
don't get recycled they're just thrown
out the windows as people drive from
work to and from the beverage store to
and from home in addition to being isour
they harm our environment and our
wildlife and we come across these bills
on my committee on Fish and Game and res
resources frequently about the
environmental impact to our wildlife of
things that we do here in the state of
New Hampshire
this is a very simple one that we can
control we can keep our dime in our hand
in our car not toss it out our
window Solid Waste is a problem in our
State Recycling is a problem in our
state I know you're going to laugh at me
when I say this but I am exactly true in
this statement this is not a problem
this is not a can we can kick down the
road anymore
I've made an effort to talk with a
variety of organizations that will be
positively and negatively impacted
initially by
a fee for
Redemption there's been a lot of support
from organizations like the conservation
law Foundation the Sierra Club the
container recycling Institute the
Bethlehem Conservation Commission the
North Country Alliance for balance
change sa Forest Lake Forest Lake
Homeowners Association
but I Al I've also heard from
organization that expressed interest
about how they're concerned about this
bill the Department of Environmental
Services the can manufacturing Institute
container recycling
Institute I'm willing to hear out those
groups and work with them Dees in their
testimony that they submitted to you and
we'll probably speak later on said that
this is an important issue to be studied
now I understand that it does take time
to figure out how to do a program well
how to do it cost
effectively but I also know this is my
beginning of my fourth year in the
house that study is a place where bills
go to die so I'm interested to studying
it if we're going to practically create
a work group and work with this
committee to study it but I'm not going
to say put it to study committee and
then have it sit on a shelf somewhere
because at the end of the day and I'll
reiterate this tourism is our second
largest economy impact on our economy
growing almost
initially up to six million6 billion
dollar this is not something that we can
just throw out the window when we're
done with it we need to protect it
respect it and by putting forth a
bill to recycle and redeem bottles and
cans that's what I'm hoping to do thank
you thank you representative there any
questions representative
fola hi thank you for taking my question
and thanks for taking the time to
consider something that's important
obviously we're all here because we care
uh about about the environment keeping
things clean I did have a question about
some of the the cons the Redemption rate
in the bill it says if the redemp rate
does not meet 90% that the commissioner
can then increase the fee I believe it's
on every the next calendar year
um I've looked around at different
states and I have yet to see a state
that actually met that Redemption rate
most fall between 50% and 80% so they're
automatically something that's baked
into this this RS this uh proposed
legislation that would automatically
continue to up that refund rate is that
something that that you looked at when
you were obviously you looked at it but
how did you pick 90% versus any other
percent given the fact that it doesn't
appear that any other State's really
been able to meet that yet well I think
we are very comfortable in understanding
that we love to set High bars for
ourselves to try and accomplish them
because if you don't aim high you know
and you fall a little short at least
you're aiming High I put that in there
to just do to do just that I'm
open-minded to talk about what are the
average rates of competitive States
especi sorry um aligning States
especially ones on our border and say
well if there is a consensus that a
percentage is lower I'm willing to
adjust that you know I created this bill
to
start loudly this
conversation so I'm willing to engage in
conversation more about how to make it
amendable so that it fits New Hampshire
as well as it fits what the industry can
see as a recycling percentage that's
realistic I have a follow on sure just
to go to that the refund rate as well
also in this legislation it's written
that the commissioner has the discretion
to change refund rates and I know that
in Vermont that that is given to the
legislature that ability uh what what
was your thought behind it being given
to the commissioner to where the the
commissioner can then just decide
unilaterally to make a rate change I
think every committee that I've heard
testimony at that I've given testimony
at that I've been part of we talk a lot
about New Hampshire letting rule changes
be the discretion of the commissioner or
the director of the agency I think
that's an important part here while we
can legislate a big picture vision of
where we want to see the state go we
have to let the professionals Who
oversee it be able to to make those
decisions and that's why I want to make
sure that it was left to the discretion
of the commissioner okay thank
you representative Bixby yes thank you
for taking my question so one uh one
thing that is mentioned in the fiscal
note which is also a concern that I I
had initially is that a number of uh of
our transfer stations um particularly in
towns where where that don't have Cur
side uh
recycling uh use the collection of
particularly aluminum and when it's at a
good rate um the plastic bottles and to
do Source separation and they can get a
very fairly High rate uh of uh of return
on those recycled items so it actually
becomes a revenue source that helps fund
the
municipal uh transfer station and I'm
wondering how this bill would affect
that by taking espec particularly the
aluminum cans out of that uh waste
stream that's going that recycling
stream that's going to the transfer
stations well I think overall you'll see
that there will be an opportunity for
Revenue to be created by the state from
this recycling program and that money
given back
to towns for recycling programs that's
in the legislation so while they may
lose some Revenue there they're going to
find some revenue from it thank
you representative Murray thank you for
taking my question one other thing that
I was curious about was in the everyday
individual if if this were to be
implemented would this be set in rules
like how would they redeem those would
that be at a per store Redemption like
if you purchased them at one entity you
had to return them to that or was this
Universal Redemption at one location
it Universal Redemption is sort of the
phrase I'll use but you'd be able to re
to return your bottles and cans to any
participating retailer so retailers
could be grocery stores they could be
convenience stores they could be
separate Redemption
Center businesses I've seen a successful
one across the border in Vermont that is
a redemption center with a convenience
store a lrat and they're building a gas
station so what they do is they create
Economic Development so but to the core
of your question you'd be able to redeem
it at any location that offers
Redemption thank
you actually I have a question for you
is there reciprocity between the
redemptions of other states where
someone buys a Canon from La pays their
10 cents and they try to turn it in here
does that reciprocity occur with other
states or is it strictly you only are
taking back cans that you would uh the
Redemption where the uh deposit was paid
within your own
State the way the program is working now
is you can return a bottle and can to
anybody that is participating in the
Redemption program where that does cause
a problem now and why I think Redemption
is important is there are cases of folks
living in other states coming into New
Hampshire to purchase their liquid
beverages not pay a sales tax because
they've come to our great state to not
pay a sales tax then they go back they
consume their bottles and cans and they
redeem it in their own state so their
state is is subsidizing their purchase
of a product here so that's something to
be looked at but right now overall you
there is no buy it in Vermont only be
able to redeem it in Vermont I don't
think that
would help folks want to recycle more we
have a lot of visitors that come here
from other states in New England for
tourism we would want them to feel
comfortable that if they
bought soda or beer in in Rhode Island
or Connecticut or Massachusetts that
they could redeem it here and vice versa
anything that they bought here without
paying a sales tax they could redeem at
home so that would be another bigger
picture conversation that I think would
have to have an at a pay grade higher
than mine where Governors would have to
look at each other and say if this is
going to affect five or six of our
states that border each other how do we
want to work together to make sure that
no one is getting sort of sandbagged in
the process So currently then if we were
to implement this program someone could
buy a purchase a can in Massachusetts
pay their their deposit there and come
back here and we'd have to refund the 10
cents
to right and the same way that someone
could buy it here not pay any sales tax
and redeem it in in Massachusetts and
Massachusetts would pay them the
Redemption and so is there at any point
within this program where sort of the
states settle up or is it just it is
what it is as of now I don't think there
is a state settling up effort but that
is that will only make sense to happen
that again that's I think legislation
that is
not when our purview any other
representative ER thank you thank you
for your testimony
today um so I live on the other side of
the state pretty near Vermont about 15
minute drive
away um every time around
uh um Earth Day uh our town goes out and
people citizens in the town go out on
the roadsides and pick up whatever trash
has been thrown there myself included I
uh I go out there with a bag and pick up
a whole bunch of stuff and lo and behold
there's a lot of cans and bottles out
there that that could have been recycled
we do have recycling programs in our
transfer station they could have even
been driven over to Vermont and gotten
redeemed but they weren't
so why would you think that this would
change that kind of
behavior because we're giving people a
financial incentive to not throw the can
out the window that right now their
financial incentive is I'm going to buy
a product and not pay a sales tax and
when I'm done with it I don't want to go
through the trouble of doing anything
else with it they don't even go through
the trouble of driving 20 miles or
whatever across the border to redeem it
by creating Redemption Center down the
street from them at the grocery store
that they go to three times a week at
the convenience store that they stop at
to get gas every day or every other day
or whatever they need to
get the recent these R Redemption opport
opportunities are there so now the
financial mindset is hey I'll hold on to
this caner bottle because I'm going to
go get groceries I'm going to go get gas
I'm going to go get pizza and the
Redemption Center's there and I'll go
redeem
it sure so what do you think is will
will there be any kind of uh
Financial investment that businesses
would have to put forth in order to put
these redemption centers into their
their establishment what would it cost
an average a small businessman to uh to
do this program I don't have those
specific numbers in front of me some are
as easy as putting in a um sort of
reverse vending machine where you put
your can of bottles in a machine and you
get tokens and you take that in some are
as easy as taking a bag and I've done
this as a test going to I live in equal
proximity to Vermont as you probably I
live in Sugar Hill I'll drive over into
to St Johnsbury you can literally drop
off a bag and they'll count them and
sort them for you and they give you a
little ticket and you go and you collect
monies so the and that's a Redemption
business they're in the business of
redeeming but the for smaller retailers
that don't want that to be their primary
business they can build uh acquire
reverse vending
machines one more do you happen to know
what the cost is of those uh reverse
vending machines not off no okay thank
you rep
stable thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question would you believe that in
Claremont people collect
cans and they take them over to mount a
scottney ver Mon and uh they uh secure
Redemption of both aluminum cans and
plastic bottles for instance the Knights
of Columbus in Claremont earns
$1400 a year with a monthly can and
bottle drive at St Mary's Church in
Claremont and that money we use for
charity and good works and I'm sure
other organizations are doing the same
there a lot of people right there close
to uh scottney across the Connecticut
River and that's wonderful and I PL that
and I would hope that with a bottle bill
in New Hampshire um environmental groups
nonprofit groups religious groups would
have bottle and can drives for
fundraising so folks will say you know
what I don't have a extra Pocket of cash
but you know what I'm going to bring all
my bottles and cans there and donate my
dimes to the Knights of Columbus so I I
think that's another incentive is that
these opportunities would exist for the
people in the state of New Hampshire
right now we don't have those
opportunities other than for them to
collect it and with concern driving over
across the border and redeeming it on
another State's
dime thank
you go ahead
repr yes I thank you for recognizing me
and my taking my question I have a
comment and then a question um first of
all my family um my family of origin
lives in Michigan and Michigan has had a
bottle bill for ages so I contacted
brother because every time I go home I
go to Kroger's with him and you know
watch everybody returning their bottles
and basically what he has said is that
um not only is it not an issue but it's
been so successful that now in the state
they're pushing for water bottles to be
redeemed because they're not and that uh
litter has virtually gone away it's it's
not an issue in the state because even
those who might toss it out there's
always somebody there who's collecting
it because they make money off of it so
I just wanted you to know that but the
question that I had and this was on um
page five and it's under Section uh four
and section five and I and I don't want
you to address it because it I I I just
feel that this is a way of um reporting
and uh uh uh reports that need to be two
preceding months it just seems to me
that this section um is a little obtuse
you know and and there's parts of it
that didn't make sense to me in terms of
trying to track the reporting and then
the refunds and that type of thing so uh
I would just like you to think about
maybe relooking at that because before I
vote on that I just need to understand
what I'm what this actually means yeah
there are a few things
that were translated um from OS um
that could use some tweaking um this was
originally from a a template of a bill
that was offered in the state of Rhode
Island um that I worked with some
environmental groups to get access to to
then refit for our state um I also know
U one of the most uh sort of biggest
ones for me is this is not a program
that's quick to undertake and I know and
I think that was also echoed in in de's
um testimon on this bill that the start
date would have to be pushed back we
need some time to plan this uh um and do
it well you know we like to say you know
here in New Hampshire let's do things
well let's do it right but let's take
the time to do it and and so that would
be an important adjustment there would
be a few adjustments obviously that I'd
want to look
at representative Bixby yes thank you
for taking my question so um on an
earlier bill today uh dealing with
extended producer
responsibility uh we heard that uh Maine
now has an extended producer
Responsibility program
for uh for packaging and they also have
a bottle bill and I was wondering if you
have any idea how those are interacting
in
vain what do you mean how they're how
they working together okay so so do are
you familiar with the with extended
producer respons responsibility so so
um so essentially beverage containers
are packaging so how does the uh
extended producer
responsibility uh law deal with the fact
that there's also a container refund uh
program uh and how does that how does
the extended producer responsibility
work in conjunction or in competition
with the bottle
there I I haven't spoken to any other um
Bill filers of bills earlier today so I
haven't really looked at that um and I'm
I can't really comment on on Main's
legislative process so I'm sort of a
little out of the loss for the details
of of what you're talking about I
apologize I don't know as a fine answer
so thank
you any other
questions rep just me made the cut sorry
thank you sorry if I had a follow on I
did have a question in here U it says
that the Attorney General shall enforce
the provisions of this chapter how
exactly would that work how would that
get enforced how would that get enforced
down to the vendor level I'm I'm kind of
curious about the cost of enforcing that
well I I think that's where a
conversation I think our our colleagues
at Dees would be better understanding of
how that would happen to happen they'll
probably talk a little bit about what
will that cost to the to the dees or to
the attorney general um but I think at
the end of the day when you're requiring
consumers to pay a um recycling fee and
then get it redeemed and monies have to
be collected and saved I think you
definitely want accountability by the
Attorney General to keep an eye on how
businesses are collecting the funds um
how they're recording it that's why
record keeping is an important part of
that um so if I if I could have a quick
follow on um I did notice that the
penalties I I was kind of comparing us
to Maine because they've had one of the
longer you know longer extensive bottle
bills and I noticed that the the
penalties look the same but they're not
quite and it it seems like they're
written much harshly in here because if
I look at Maine Maine's looking at you
know they'll have a $100 per uh per
violation and here you know it it
actually talks about $100 per B model
which could if I'm looking at this
correctly maybe I'm not L I'd have to go
back and look that it says any person
including a bottle distributor retailer
or Redemption Center who violates the
provision shall be subject to a civil
penalty of the greater of $100 for each
container um so I just I just wondered
if if maybe you that was that was
intentional or maybe that was just a
that wasn't intentional because I don't
think that that's a little too
heavy-handed again you know part
of what we're creating what I'm trying
to create here is is legislation that's
that's never occurred for occurred
before it's one thing to amend existing
legislation that we might have in the
state um so this is a sort of a work in
progress and again U maybe this is the
appropriate time for me to say I am open
to you know working on this bill
especially with Dees with can
manufacturing um Institute who you know
not only said we see raw materials going
up and their their public statement was
recycling is important to the industry
because that's going to drive the the
raw material cost up for our Goods
organizations like that I'm very open to
hear from um because they know this
business better than I do and while I
don't want to tell them how to do their
business and I am a little bit with this
bill I want them to be able to say if
you're going to tell us how to do our
business can you at least help help us
have us go down this path because
that'll be the best path for us to
process I don't want to make this a bill
that angers the industry I want it to be
a bill that the industry wants to
support wants to publicize and say look
folks we're going to recycle now because
it's good for our business it's good for
your pocketbook and it's good for our
state thank
you all right well we thank you rep Ean
and got everybody's questions in now
thank you again Mr chair thank you stent
colleagues I really do appreciate the
time today thank you
next we'll have rep cat McGee from
Hillsboro
27 good afternoon chairman PR thank you
it's nice to be with uh Ena again um I'm
representative cat McGee from Hillsboro
27 Hollis um I serve there with
representative
hola and uh I'm pleased to be with you
today to offer my support for HB
1652 as my colleague from Sugar Hill
testified this is a bill that we feel
Time Has Come although I'd say that
we're still not all uh we're all not
agreed on that point so although
representative Egan and I are fully
aware that New Hampshire marches to its
own drum and we often don't do things
just because all the other states around
us or in New England are doing that um
we know that we can't avoid the problem
of growing Solid Waste piles around our
state uh we are arriving late to the
party in creating a plan that slows the
need for more and more solid waste
disposal
sites all over New Hampshire the way to
slow the need for more sites is to
divert Solid Waste streams before they
enter the
landfills while it would be great to
continue paying to ship our trash out to
sea or to China on a barge that
eliminates the waste from our site the
real it is recyclable materials like
plastic aluminum and glass are growing
in value and implementing a plan to
manage this waste so it doesn't end up
in a landfill is a bipartisan economic
issue bottle bills have been attempted
before and as you can see by reviewing
H1
1652 implementing a program is not a
simple proposition the Department of
Environmental Services is a logical
Agency for oversight and they contribute
to the fiscal note by saying they have
no existing resources trained to
administer such a program or to
coordinate the necessary enforcement
with other agencies and they mentioned
doj but recycling of bottles and cans as
defined in hb1 1652 Is Not A New Concept
in all the surrounding New England
states recycling is being done by the
same bottlers who are claiming
opposition to New Hampshire's bill and
the process of bottle redemption has
become easy and familiar citizens
understand understand what it means
they're familiar with it from other
states and so if we implemented
something like this here it wouldn't be
a change that would be uh difficult in
order to um secure adoption I think uh
bottles have a Redemption value and that
means that more people get them where
they need to go um cycling back into the
packaged material stream as opposed to
the landfills and I think as um as
materials in in terms of conservation as
materials become higher in value I think
even bottlers um are looking for those
materials back they want to recycle the
glass and the plastic and the aluminum
rather than trying to create it all from
scratch so there's an there's an
inherent value to this trash if it is
separated out of the waist streams uh
and put back into the system for use
again so this is a simple uh that is the
simple purpose of this bill while we do
not have to reinvent the wheel or answer
every issue in order to move forward
what we really do need to do is use the
power of the legislature to make a
decision that a bottle Bill helps New
Hampshire manage its Solid Waste Problem
by helping us reclaim and redirect
recyclable materials that can be used to
reduce Municipal costs and other costs
manufacturer costs as well uh opponents
claim there's no need to do this and
there's no benefit in recycling however
bottlers are now operating in a
manufacturing environment where having
direct access access to recycled bottles
and cans saves them money as well so
that is why I believe this is a bill
whose time has come for the State of New
Hampshire facing up to our waste problem
saving money and protecting the
environment are all bipartisan issues
here and I ask that you support hb1 1652
with your vote of a to pass thank
you thank you representative McGee we
really appreciate your coming and
testifying today anybody from the
committee have
questions representative Bixby thank you
for dating my question um I'm a little
bit confused about the um the the
financial mechanism so when you when you
buy a um a bottled beverage you pay a 10
10cent deposit on that if you return it
then you get your 10 cents back what
does the how does the there some was a
0.035 cents for the Redemption Center
that is um uh handling the redeemed
bottles administrative fee right so
where does that where does that um that
administrative fee come
from um I I'm I'm afraid I don't know
okay because that's a that's a stumper
question representative I just it seems
like if if you if you oh it looks like
represent even youan might have an
answer yeah sure please
[Music]
do so in every program in the states
that I looked at there is never 100% of
recycling so the the Redemption so not
everybody gets their dime back or asks
for their dime back they basically say
okay whatever um and there are bottles
and cans that disappear right end up at
the bottom of a lake they end up in the
back of your pickup truck for three
years so that administration fee comes
out of sort of the um the fees not
redeemed okay so so if we actually met
the ideal of 100% recycling then there
would be a shortfall of administrative
fees right which is why as
representative hola mentioned quite
accurately 90% is aggressive
you average states are in
the 50s to 70s per. so there is that not
fees not redeemed that covers
administrative
fees thank
you yes representative Capital this is
just I'm curious if if you know thanks
for taking my question uh so if the
average Redemption fee is like 50 or 60
or 70% how does that compare to
Municipal recycling rates anybody
I'm trying to be respectful if the
questions for her yeah for either of you
so then repeat
it how how does how do Redemption
collection rates compared to the
recycling rates you know in a municipal
recycling
program I I didn't look into Municipal
recycling programs I've always looked at
Statewide program or Statewide
yeah representative did you have
information on that I know you've worked
in that area yeah I think uh yeah let me
just read this in the information we got
from the conservation law Foundation uh
basically they said uh states with
container deposit laws a recycled
aluminum pet and glass at a rate of 78%
59% and
64% conversely states without container
deposit laws recycle these materials at
much lower r
36% for aluminum 14% for pet and 14% for
glass so than there's encourages
recycling I would add that I did speak
with um the person who runs our DPW in
town because I know we've had a very uh
successful recycling program in Hollis
um our transfer station is
legendary and um our DPW person was
responsible for running that transfer
station for years and she's also um um
involved with regional uh transfer
station owners and many of those
transfer station owners are operating
those Enterprises um in order to bring
money back to the town and lower taxes
and ours is no different and she was
excited about the idea I think they've
heard about this for many years and so
she wasn't um you know she she was still
cynical a little bit about whether or
not anything would happen in the state
but she did say that they would be very
excited and very pleased if we did
something like this because they think
that it would increase the amount of
recyclables that they would end up
handling and it would end up lowering
lowering the cost of that operation and
bringing money back to the town so I
think that that's another benefit that
we hadn't touched on on the municipal
side that I think several towns would
take advantage of Representative Bixby
yes uh thank you for taking my question
would uh transfer stations be eligible
to become our redemption
centers yes that would be one of the
places I mean that would be a logical
place because I think a lot of them are
already set up to do separation of trash
what you really want is you just want to
get it separated out of the waist stream
so it doesn't become Solid Waste in a
place where it's more expensive to
separate it out so that you can use it
again um so that's you know part of the
economics of it is uh asking people to
help you get it before it becomes
something that's more expensive to to
recover any further
questions I just want to clarify
representative Bigby's uh question from
before that the distributor is the is
the person that reimburses
the the per container so as much as the
state gets the dime and gives the dime
back when the distributor gets the
bottle back they contribute to the state
for getting property
back that helps cover that
administrative all right seeing no more
questions I thank you for your
testimony before I uh call up Mr norc
from New Hampshire Dees if anyone is
missing a cell phone and left it in the
men's room Heather has it on her
desk I don't
think
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael norc uh
representing the solid waste management
Bureau for the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental
Services and uh many of the comments
that the agency has has already been
alluded to by representative vegan and
representative McGee uh
primarily I guess I should say we we are
not taking a position on the bill and
although we do support
efforts to increase recycling in New
Hampshire uh we just have a couple of
concerns about how this effort might be
implemented um primarily related to the
resources necessary for the Department
to administer the various
responsibilities that it would be
assigned under this bill um you know we
would be responsible for adopting new
administrative rules uh reviewing
reports evaluating the Redemption rate
for the State uh you know possibly Chang
that Redemption uh value as well as the
handling fee that would be um reimbursed
to uh redemption centers so there's a
number of responsibilities that the
department would have to undertake we
don't currently have resources to do
that and this bill does not
establish um the resources or the
funding necessary for us to undertake
those new
responsibilities um I just want to note
that this bill as written would current
you know basically would take monies
that are not claimed or deposits that
are not claimed and split them 5050
between the general fund and the State
Recycling fund the State Recycling fund
is established under RSA
9C and its sole purpose is to allow for
containers and Recycling services for
state agencies um so this the the
unclaimed funds would go to to help with
that um that the funding yet necessary
for State Recycling at State AG gencies
and state buildings um but it we believe
that that funding may be better placed
uh and to use the resources that would
be necessary to implement this
bill our other U concern is that the
timeline for imple implementation of
this bill may be a little um
optimistic uh as currently introduced uh
the effective date for this bill would
be January 1st
2023 um
and as we all know bills typically will
get passed in the later half of the
year and so if this bill was to pass say
in July August of this year that would
leave us a few months maybe three four
months to be able to do a lot of the
initial administrative duties including
potentially trying to develop a new
position to help us administer this so
it's just a lot to try to cram into a
couple months Before the bill actually
becomes
effective so while we definitely don't
have any concerns with the idea of
increasing recycling we do have some
concerns about how this might be
implemented um we're happy to support
any further you know discussions on the
on the issue um and I'm happy to take
any questions that you might have at
this at this
time any questions from Mr nor
representative
Murray I did have a question you in the
testimony you submitted cited I believe
$100,000 per year um but that was not
cited in the fiscal note and I was just
curious if that came after the fiscal
note was it released
or uh I haven't noticed thank you
representative Murray I haven't noticed
that discrepancy in the fiscal
note um that was information that we did
submit to legislative budget assistant
to to help them develop the fiscal note
um
um it seems that perhaps that
information did not oh it is it's on
page of the fiscal note it's the second
page of the fiscal
note my apologies I was looking at the
um estimated increase decrease
Matrix okay so and that and just to be
clear that cost is uh for the position
itself um there may be other
administrative costs that we're just not
able to anticipate at this time thank
you any other questions for Mr nor
representative Bixby yes if we were to
uh try to uh go ahead and
um amend this bill would uh your
department be able to help out uh
nailing down a little bit more
specifically what what uh costs you need
to have covered beyond the that position
so that uh an appropriation could be
requested uh thank you representative
viby for the the question I I I think
you know we would certainly be open to
having a conversation about that um
because we've never administered a
program like this before it's a little
bit difficult to know exactly all the
the costs that might that might be
entailed I think at the very minimum uh
supporting a staff person to be able to
help support the effort would be our
primary
concern representative
Perez thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um in your testimony
you say that uh Dees is not taking a
position on this bill but some of the
things that you saying is like uh kind
of like contrary to what you're saying
because some of the things that they're
like saying that it will have a negative
impact um can you can you tell me what
changes can we do to this build in order
for Dees to say okay we will work with
this field because it seems
like you saying you you got the de is is
not taking position but for for what I
understanding is you guys really taking
a position and and it's like the
comments that you making is a an
opposition of the bill kind of like uh
can you tell me what exactly what
language that needs to be changed in
this bill in order for you guys to work
with uh the sponsors of this Bill thank
you representative Perez for the
question um we are not taking a position
because we don't have we don't have a
position on the merits of the bill
itself or on the concept itself our
primary concern is with how it would be
implemented in a way that uses limited
State resources to the
greatest U you know the most efficient
way U primarily our concerns are related
to how it would Implement how it would
impact the
department and the fact that I think as
you the committee heard earlier today
from previous hearings the solid waste
management Bureau at Dees has been
challenged for a number of years in
terms of resources and Staffing to be
able to keep up with our current
requirements like updating the solid
waste management plan doing standard rul
making um a number of other duties um
that we have been challenged to keep up
with so if we're going to take a new
initiative like this and put it into
law our primary concern is just that
there needs to be some consideration for
the resources that would be necessary to
put it into
practice followup
sure okay so my followup question is
what Dees will tell committee members
they're really concerned about the
recycling issue that we want to that
they want the communities to be working
in and try to protect uh the environment
and by doing that um that uh recycling
will help that protect the environment
what a is was told these people they're
ready to work in doing the recycling by
the is saying that this is not going to
help what what would you tell
them uh represent Perez I'm not sure
that I follow your line of questioning
yeah
so I keep hearing from from members of
different communities that they're ready
to do the recycling the bottle recycling
and they takeen bottles to per month or
they taken into another state because we
don't offer the money here why would you
tell the people that they're ready in
our communities and they're ready to do
but they taken the
money to another state they're taking
those bottles instead of then you know
we you know we can help them here in you
hire instead of and take them to another
state I I agree with you that that
logically speaking it makes a lot of
sense for you know any money that is
going to other states it would make more
sense to have it stay here if we had if
we had a system in place to to manage
that thank
you representative fola hi there I thank
you for taking my call or thank you for
taking my call thank you for taking my
question um you had mentioned before
that the costs are
indeterminate and obviously this
program's been tried in other states
have is anyone from Dees looked at the
cost of other states what it the
expenditures revenues the ratio to that
to when you assisted with the fiscal
note is there any kind of context
obviously New Hampshire is not the first
person going to try this so This Wheels
been invented somewhere do you have any
information on that representative hom
that's a great question um unfortunately
when we're assigned the the the fiscal
note worksheet we have very limited time
to actually turn around and do it I
think in an ideal situation it would be
that that kind of analysis would be
warranted um we did not do that for this
fiscal note
um one of the things to take
consideration when you ask other state
agencies the costs um
that they may be operating under
different statutory authorities
different you know regulatory
authorities uh so it sometimes takes a
little time to Parts out Apples to
Apples but yeah that is a that is a
valid point Thank
you any other
questions seeing none Mr nor thank you
for your testimony thank
you next we'll uh call on John Swan from
Dalton needs requested five minutes to
speak good afternoon chairman Pearl and
uh rest of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony my name is John
Swan I'm the founder of save Forest Lake
I live in Dalton New Hampshire uh I'm
excited about the prospects of uh House
Bill 1652 to help bring New Hampshire
out of the environmental Dark Ages uh
we're surrounded by by states that have
bottle bills in fact uh it was brought
up earlier that uh some entities collect
bottles uh in New Hampshire obviously
they did not pay a deposit and took
those across state lines into a
neighboring state that is a um crossb
Redemption it's illegal by the way um so
just an
FYI
um today's themes what have we talked
about all day waste
aversion epr and a circular
economy uh obviously waste is a problem
I know you've seen the data you've seen
statistics uh if not um the
container
deposit Institute sent
out uh container recycling Institute
sent out a testimony to you they could
not be here today uh because of covid
and no remote access available for
Testimony but um they did send out some
great information especially comparing
um recycling rates in states that do not
have a bottle deposit Bill versus states
that do in fact uh 10 cents uh we we
opted for 10 cents because you can see
the rates uh in Oregon and Michigan they
are near 90% in terms of a recycling
rate uh plus as uh the representatives
before me spoke to um container deposit
laws give manufacturers which they want
now a cleaner raw material to work with
instead of having to use uh virgin
resources um I I also wanted to note
that I was encouraged by the testimony
from the representative of the transfer
station from the town of Meredith
earlier uh he stated basically and it's
a sad State of Affairs relative to
recycling but they're barely making any
money to quote him relative to recycling
and uh he there's obviously Market
fluctuations and one of the big
questions he brought up and it's well
documented is what to do with glass so
look at it here in New Hampshire we can
address several of those problems that
we're facing waste diversion keeping
recyclable material out of
landfills um what to do with
glass uh also protecting municipalities
from Market fluctuations as you saw in
2018 with China's uh um national sword
policy about contaminated recyclables um
that had a real drastic impact on
municipalities throughout the country
and uh as well as covid so this will
insulate municipalities in New Hampshire
from Market fluctuations so again
Representatives um McGee and Egan did a
great job in presenting um I fully
support this bill I did want to make
note of one uh it was on page three of
four from the uh container recycling
Institute Institute letter that the
committee received from Susan Collins um
at the very top she talked about
financial benefits of a New Hampshire
deposit law um and if you'll just permit
me she notes that the fiscal note
attached to this bill did not contain
any bottomline dollar figures of how the
state might benefit from a deposit law
CRI has estimated however that the state
could reap as much as $14 million in
unclaimed deposit Revenue annually that
figure was arrived at by multiplying an
estimated 1.4 billion deposit units sold
annually by 10% being the inverse of a
90% Redemption rate and then by the
10-cent deposit so $14 million gain
could be realized annually by the state
of New Hampshire and if you will note in
some of the um fiscal Notes The Liquor
Commission noted that they could see a
reduction in beer tax revenue by an
estimated $6 million a year and then the
liquor store also mentioned the Liquor
Commission mentioned the cost of the uh
reverse vending machines which was
brought up earlier um averaging anywhere
from 10,000 to 25,000 per uh with an
estimate of approximately $640,000 to
1.6 million for 65 machines so if you
add those cost figures um the $4 million
gain as CRI points out would be greater
than the losses enumerated in the fiscal
note so again I think this would help
the state of New Hampshire with what
we're talking about earlier uh one of
our concerns being the fact that uh
recyclable material is being
landfilled um as representative Aon
mentioned earlier you go out you do the
uh roadside cleanups I do it almost
every day I'm so sick and tired of
seeing Twisted Tea and Bud Light cans on
my road but as you point out when you do
those roadside cleanups and they go in
those blue keep New Hampshire beautiful
bags provided by the industry uh who
typically opposed the bottle bill
those dirty cans and bottles wind up in
the
landfill so that's something to keep in
mind uh and I will say I did temporarily
or not temporarily but a short period Of
My Life I Lived in nework state they do
have a deposit law and I can tell you
roadside litter was not a problem in New
York state especially in the uh um City
area where you do have people who will
scour the area for those recyclables uh
to redeem and uh obviously add to their
income come so anyway I hope you will
support uh House Bill 1652 and again
thank you for your time today and
chairman thank you very much for
stacking these bills today to save us uh
uh more trips than needed to come down
here to conquer thank you you're welcome
thanks for coming down and your
testimony today any questions for Mr
Swan seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you safe for
s next we have uh Kevin dagel from the
New Hampshire Grocers
Association good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Kevin dagel I'm the
vice president of the New Hampshire
grossers Association uh for those of you
not familiar familiar with our
association we represent both the
independent and chain convenience stores
grocery stores as well as their
wholesalers and their
suppliers uh today I'd like to address
three areas of concern for Grocers these
being the impact to sales the unsanitary
storage of the containers and finally
the impact on the lowincome consumer
since the mid 1970s when the first
bottle bill was introduced this
Association has consistently testified
that New Hampshire is very fortunate and
at the same time dependent on crossb
sales the Undisputed fact remains that
had a minimum 40% of all our customers
live outside of New Hampshire long-term
members of the legislature have heard US
Express on numerous occasions that every
time any excise tax tax is increased
even by a penny travel trips to our
state are reduced that first penny
affects the consumer who has to travel
the furthest and as you add more pennies
of tax those consumers closer to our
borders decide not to travel here as
well in the case of this bill the
returnable depos PA it is an excise tax
because the 10 cents you would receive
is not worth packing all those
containers into your car and driving
them all the way back to New Hampshire
not to mention the fact the 10cent tax
is more than any of our neighboring
states Grocers have always known that
when costs increase consumers will
search out other locations with lower
prices unfortunately for us this bill
would mean reduced sales as consumers
return to shopping in their own State
another consequence for food stores
would be the unsanitary storage of
Beverage containers adjacent to food
storage beverage containers contain
products made with sugar if not
thoroughly cleaned out they will attract
insects which attract bugs which attract
rodents then there's the people Factor
not everyone is as respectful as you or
I may be from personal observation I
have seen what types of foreign matter
can be placed in bottles and cans and
it's not pretty these returns then
compromise the rest of the clean
containers this would quickly lead to
Greater pest control costs for all
retailers another concern we have is the
taxing of these products the segments of
our society who can least afford it I'm
talking about those that use
supplemental funds like Wick and snap to
purchase their groceries I saw that
there's a carveout that made exempt
infant formula in meal replacement but
it doesn't take into account Shoppers
buying juices water or dairy drinks and
then having having higher costs
associated with this purchase with their
limited funding in closing for over 40
years the New Hampshire legislature has
decided against implementing refundable
deposit mandates because industry has
voluntarily developed better and more
successful ways to address the issues of
litter Solid Waste reduction and
recycling education programs the food
industry has been a very profitable
partner for generating State revenues
and increasing employment for these
reasons we ask you to find House Bill
1652 in expedient to legislate thank you
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
Mr chairman thank you Mr dagel any
questions
for representative
Duty yes thank you for taking my
question I'm a little confused as to how
it would be a tax if you can get the
money back so the way it works with my
brother is he collects the bottles he
goes to Kroger every week okay so he
takes his bottles back on a monthly
basis gets a little ticket out gets five
or $10 back and he uses that to pay his
groceries so how would that be
considered a tax on lowincome
people well it's a tax because it's not
immediate return so now they're having
to with their limited funds whether they
have a wick voucher that states I can
get x y and z now I need to buy
additional products whether it's milk
tomato juice pineapple juice they're
needing to put that upfront cost there
we're we're here now because people
aren't recycling or the images they're
not recycling they now then have to take
these containers and bring them
somewhere what are the chances that are
going to do that that's when it becomes
a tax becomes a tax when the family
comes up from Connecticut buys their
their groceries for a couple of weeks
because they're they're staying at the
lake and they take their products back
with them they're not redeeming them so
it's a tax it's not an immediate return
upon their
investment thank you any other
questions I guess I have
one what do you think and you may not be
able to answer this what do you think
the probabilities would be that many of
your grosser members would be interested
in hosting these uh you know maybe the
machines or or Redemption Center within
the facilities that they currently have
would they do you think they have room
enough to do this or I mean the machine
maybe but a full-blown Redemption
Center I mean I do a lot of grocery
store delivery I know how tight they are
for space that's the reason for my
question yeah not not having consulted
with with our members as to you know the
room and and where they do it I'll go on
my own personal experience I come from a
chain store um we had a reverse
engineered recycling vending machine in
in the back or in the front um it's
absolutely disgusting what comes through
there
whether it's somebody who has a quarter
quarter of a can left they throw it in
there to get the five cent uh the person
who uses it as their their spatoon um
not to mention everything else they
throw that in there then you have a
16-year-old kid I need the vending
machine empty let's go empty it they
take that they're not really concerned
with what we're going to do with the
product they bag it up they take the two
they're usually boxes about the size of
this table filled with a garbage bag
they take the garbage bags they put it
in into a shopping cart and then not
thinking they then take that shopping
cart go through the whole store to the
back room which is adjacent to where all
your food is so you've compromised a lot
of things would I want us do I think
they'd want to do that I don't believe
so thank you I know it was a bit of a
speculative question I sort of was
referring to my own experience of
delivering produce but thank you you're
any other questions oh representative
Aaron thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony today uh I had asked
this of a previous speaker I wonder if
you know what the cost would be to a
retailer for one of these machines where
you place your bottle in and it squishes
it up and yeah exactly a reverse
engineer trending machine you're looking
at a minimum probably a $10,000
investment that's for a Bare Bones if
you're looking to get something more
along the lines of efficiency and
capacity you could be upwards of
152,000 okay and
and the maintenance of that machine
because I know I used when I lived in
Connecticut we had a a those a row of
them by a Big Y or whatever it was and
we went in and put in our bottles and
everything but half of them were usually
not working at the time right so in
terms of maintaining those machines uh
and paying somebody to come and fix them
what what would that cost a retailer
right depending upon the number of
machines that you have there may be one
that's in service or the only one you
have may be out of service again you
you've got substances that are being
still remaining in the bottle or the can
redeeming that gums up the whole works
of everything most of the time it's an
outside contractor outside service
person that's contracted through your
arrangement with the the third party to
do that you could be looking within 24
hours 48 hours to have your machine
serviced thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right I got one card left
so if you want to send the blue sheet in
my direction uh Scott Shire from the New
Hampshire buer Distributors
Association
good afternoon thanks for making the
time for everybody today I know it's
been a long day for you um for the
record my name is Scott Shire I work for
the New Hampshire beer distributors
Association I'm their executive director
and I've worked in the beer industry for
about 20 years um I'm G to kind of skip
what I was planning on talking about and
just focus in on a couple of key points
in the interest of time and maybe
address some of the um the comments that
came up earlier um and I'll talk a
little bit about beer and some kind of
numbers that you might be able to um wow
your friends with at uh at the next
dinner party in terms of beer in New
Hampshire um first off um I have a lot
of respect for the intent of the bill
and for the time that uh the co-sponsors
put into uh this legislation but I don't
agree with everything that was presented
earlier and I'll just tick off a couple
of
things pretty quickly first of all um it
came up at one point that people don't
really care about the environment um
people in general just sort of a general
statement and I I really want to
disagree with that because I think
people do really care especially here in
New Hampshire and uh I've been lucky
enough to be involved with uh
environmental groups um through my kids
uh and their school as well as um
serving as a volunteer on the the board
of directors for New Hampshire the
beautiful that does a lot of U
Educational Funding and and Research
into uh making recycling easier for
people um I also disagree with the fact
that this will save money um and and
maybe cost less and I'll explain that
more in a minute when we talk about some
of the economics with raw materials um
and I I disagree with the statement that
this will help tourism actually I think
it's the opposite I think it'll make us
less competitive with our neighbor
States um I think New Hampshire has a
unique selling proposition right now
that our uh our our states to the left
to the right and to the to the bottom of
us don't have um and being different is
good in marketing people want to come
here because there's no tax and because
there's no bottle bill and I think
increasing um a bottle having a bottle
bill first of all that's 100% higher
than our neighboring states is going to
make us less competitive rather than
more competitive so I don't think we
should do what our neighboring states
doing to sort of keep up um I've talked
to a couple of the executive directors
in states that have my role in uh in
Massachusetts in particular in Vermont
and they do not love their bottle bills
and are a little bit envious of New
Hampshire not having one um they said
they lose a lot of business to New
Hampshire because people come over the
border to shop and I agree with them and
I agree with what Mr dagel said earlier
between 40 and 50% of Total Beer Revenue
goes to people who don't live in New
Hampshire so they're bu buying these
products and spending money in our state
um but generally speaking they're not
even leaving the containers here um so
that's that's another thing um and in
terms of helping towns and and transfer
centers I don't agree with that either I
think this bottle bill will rob transfer
centers cities and towns of Revenue um
especially given the situation that was
brought up earlier and one thing that I
do agree on is that producers want their
raw materials back and raw materal costs
are on the rise and have been um for
several years especially aluminum and
I'll talk specifically about aluminum
cans and beer now and just give you a
couple of facts so New Hampshire sells
about 42 million gallons of beer a year
which if you equate that to a case
equivalent which is 24 12 ounce cans
that's about 18 million cases a year um
generally speaking New Hampshire is
number one on the per capita consumption
list and it's not really because we all
love to party and drink beer uh it's
really because most of our volume is
going to out ofers tourists or people
who are shopping and taking it back with
them so if you do some some basic math
using those figures it accounts to about
432 million beer
containers in the state of New Hampshire
any year and of that
65% of those containers are aluminum
either aluminum cans or aluminum Bott
bottles the stadium type bottles that
are 16 oun with a a Twist off that you
might find at a a venue an event
venue so if we say that um you know 60%
which is conservative it's probably
closer to 65 since the pandemic as
people shifted more into cans than
bottles because of cube efficiency
freight cost going up um that's 259
million um beer cans in the state and if
we said half of those were claimed by
transfer centers and using the spot rate
on the open market uh for aluminum in
September of
2021 that equates to about 3 cents per
can this 24 cans in a pound of aluminum
and aluminum's about was about 72 cents
a pound um back in September so that's
3.8 million dollars a year almost $4
million um conservatively that goes to
transfer centers for redeeming aluminum
only and aluminum's valuable because not
only is it the highest price Comm
package commodity but it's infinitely
recyclable and it's super easy for
consumers to know that it's recyclable
if you hold up a soda can or a beer can
and say is this recyclable I think
pretty much everybody in the room would
say yes it is we understand but if I
held up
this plastic
folder I wouldn't know if that's
recyclable or not I could look for the
number and maybe figure it out or a
piece of waxed paper cardboard or
cardboard that has four color printing
it's very confusing when you get into
consumer products in terms of what can
actually be recycled cleanly and what
can't be so aluminum is great for that
um this is the highest rate of aluminum
cans in the beer industry since they've
been tracking U sales and and remember
and some of you in this room may
remember cans didn't start being uh on
the scene in mainstream America uh
Supermarket shelves until the 1950s
prior to that there were it was all
glass or Kake for beer and over the
years it shifted from 20% 30% worked its
way up to about two years ago about 6040
and now after the pandemic it's it's
closer to
65% aluminum so the transfer centers
want these cans they're going to do
everything they can to get them um I
live in Durham and my Transfer Center
has uh containers put out for people to
put their aluminum cans in so they're
separating them because they know that
it's more valuable than the cardboard or
anything else that they're going to
collect and they do quite well with uh
returning those things and selling on
the the open market like I said they're
shredded they get bailed they get
shredded they get uh heated into molten
lava and then they make ignant out of
them and and sell it again and recycle
them and they can do that infinitely so
I don't know what the extent of the
problem is in New Hampshire landfills
for aluminum cans in general um but I
would guess that's not the only offender
I think there's probably a lot of fast
food waste products in there and and
other things other containers that are
not addressed by this bill so so I'm I'm
thinking that this is not the main issue
with uh with this with in terms of
filling up landfills and recycling uh
product packaging I will tell you that
um everybody in my organization and a
lot of our Retail Partners really do
care about recycling in fact we ship all
of our pallet wrap back which is the
sort of cellophane type product that
goes around a pallet to keep the beer in
place while they're shipping it uh we
recycle all that voluntarily send it out
of state when we get a full container
load and it goes to TRX decking and they
make composite um Wood Products out of
it um we also serve with uh with the
Grocers to take back plastic bags which
the same thing gets get converted and I
think that over the last 40 years has
been a real Step Up in terms of
educational Outreach for recycling and
more people are doing it primarily
because of efforts by local transfer
centers but also U efforts of community
groups like New Hampshire the
um so in conclusion I guess and I'll
I'll take be happy to take any questions
you know this bill um has a good intent
um but I think it's the wrong vehicle to
try to get this done um I think that
we're talking about a a 10% deposit um
there may be a little bit more wiggle
room uh in terms of pricing but at a
5cent deposit which is competitive with
our other states excuse me I don't think
there's any way this program can make
any money um I don't know where where
those figures came from before um but I
you know I look at $4 million being
taken away from Municipal transfer
centers and I also look at the reduction
in the beer tax which using the numbers
from 2021 would be a $5 million hit to
the general fund annually if if this
bill were to pass so between those two
that's a negative $9 million bogy um
plus there's a lot of things that are
vague or unsolved for not a lot of
specifics and how this would actually be
executed so I just don't think it's
ready for prime time and I would
encourage you to to vote to itl this
bill be happy to take any
questions thank you any uh questions
representative
Kaplan yeah thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question uh you
mentioned that was it $40
million uh that uh that the
municipalities would lose this took took
effect uh and that I think that was
based on a 50% recycling rate is that
correct that's correct where did you get
that figure because we heard it could be
as low as 177% ear yeah I just I just
basically to did math on case sales from
uh the prior year and then um
anticipated 50% of those products were
immediately going out of state and then
of the remaining 50% maybe only 50% of
those were being recycled so it would
effectively be a 25% recycling rate so
that could be you know higher or lower
but this is a ballpark at this point but
I'm actually using real
data you're welcome thanks for the
question any other
questions seeing none we thank you for
your testimony thank you very much all
right I did have one final card committ
from Adam Schmidt from the New Hampshire
beverage Association he needs two
minutes we're GNA hold you to
it thank you Mr chairman I will stay
well within that two minutes um I know
it's been a long day for you all I just
handed around testimony from bried
deatley as I mentioned a moment ago my
name is not Bri deatley it's Adam
Schmidt um she was hoping to be here
today uh she's a expert on this these
types of bills for the New Hampshire
beverage Association this would include
non-alcoholic beverage manufacturers
think Coke Pepsi K Dr Pepper those types
of folks so her testimony details uh our
association's concerns many of them you
heard from Mr dagel and Mr sh for me so
I won't go through all of that with you
I think the one thing I would mention is
you know Solid Waste has become a a
pretty uh higher level Topic in the
legislature over the last few years and
one of the bills that you did pass last
session created a solid waste working
group over at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services no
chairman Pearl serves on that working
group I think that's the area where if
you're going to do something in this
space that might be the best place to
look at designing something that would
work well um rather than a piece of
legislation is based upon the questions
and the testimony you've heard today
might not be fully baked yet but that
working group would include the correct
stakeholders the right people to Hash
something like this out and perhaps
bring It Forward at at a future date so
more of the details about that thought
are in the testimony but I thought it
was just a little bit something
different you hadn't heard yet so far
today so with that I hope I stayed
within my two minutes and uh thank you
you did indeed thank you any uh
questions
seeing none we thank you anybody else
that would like to
speak okay I have the blue sheet here we
had seven people signed in five in
support one
opposed and with that I will close the
hearing on House Bill
1652 I want to thank everybody for the
time you spent today and coming down and
giving us testimony we received a lot of
really good information so I do
appreciate it committee members we have
um hearing scheduled next Tuesday
beginning at 9:00 a.m. they're posted in
the calendar so other than that any uh
anything that anybody in the committee
needs to bring
forward um so uh in terms of next week
you had mentioned in a previous
discussion with me that there might be
some executive sessions uh are you
expecting that and if so would it be
possible to schedule those in the
afternoon since one of our members can't
make
it I do anticipate that we could perhaps
EXA some of these bills but I think
we'll uh certainly would like to talk to
my caucus as I'm sure you would yours as
well and see where we have a consensus
on bills so we'll do that and and decide
and and I I imagine we can do them in
the afternoon I don't see any reason why
we can't um I think I've scheduled the
morning tight enough so there probably
wasn't isn't any room anyway I I try to
keep my scheduling really close thank
you only other thing I'll mention to the
committee I had to duck out earlier
today for a few minutes for a chair's
meeting the deadline on early bills has
been moved up slightly because of um
we're anticipating a house session in
the week of the 17th rather than our
deadline being the 17th so we're going
to need um to have our early bills done
and out of committee prior in noon on
the 10th of February so just as as an
update so the bills that we do have that
are early we have to be paying attention
to that
yes I believe it is so that's a
conversation we'll need to have fairly
soon okay with that if there's nothing
else uh have a safe ride home and I
appreciate you all coming thank
you
e
for